foreign well
donald trump is now the first president
in u.s history
to be impeached twice and uh i wouldn't
be surprised if he you know if if in
fact trump had ended up winning the
election he would have
been impeached like four or five times
because they would just keep doing it
and i guess the joke is that if he ended
up you know winning it would have been
like 3 000 impeachments but here we go
this time several republicans actually
joined in i think the number is 10
and already conservatives republicans
trump supporters are saying well they
just ended their careers and i think
that makes a lot of sense considering
the republican party still likes trump
overwhelmingly
and in fact according to rasmussen
trump's approval rating actually went up
after january 6th which shows you
just how much people really love this
man well donald trump came out today put
out a video
and he said no violence no law breaking
in reference to any upcoming rallies or
protests
and now we're hearing the national guard
has been briefed on very serious
terroristic threats
that are expected around the
inauguration so i hope that turns out to
be nothing
they've got national guard troops all
over the capitol building all over dc i
think they're bringing in what like 20
000 is that the number some ridiculous
number
so we're going to go through this and
we're also going to talk about the big
tech censorship because the other
breaking news
snapchat took a brave and bold step
banning donald trump he's already
suspended but they announced that
they're going to be permanently banning
him
on the 20th so okay i didn't realize was
trump was a big snapchat user is that a
thing i don't use snapchat so
so we're going to talk a lot about it
and we've got one of the foremost
experts on big tech censorship alan
bakari he's hanging out
yeah i'm going to introduce yourself hi
i'm alan bakari
i've been uh writing about big tech
censorship since 2015
at breitbart news and uh not to say we
told you so but we told yourself
you did and you guys didn't you guys
also put out that video of google like
crying when trump won
yes this was a few days after the
election we got our hound on this
internal video at google and we
published the whole thing at breitbart
news you can still find it online
and not censored yet and this was three
days after the election or two days
after the election even and they just in
total meltdown at what had happened
they couldn't process it they had no
plan they said they had no plan they had
that they said they had no idea what the
trump administration was going to do
because they hadn't they hadn't possibly
conceived that he could have won
and they also more importantly started
talking about their plans to crush the
populist movement
to make it in the words of one executive
a blip in history
and they did this was the story of the
2016 2020 election
sorry complete interference by the tech
companies and it was culminating in the
ban of trump himself
and then it was a blip the populist
thing popped up and now they
suppressed it but i don't think it's
over and that's that's kind of the point
of what we're seeing
they they i guess they seem to think
that people will think what they tell
them to think
and that's partially true if you could
shut down the internet
which they can't because we're already
seeing trump supporters going
underground setting up new networks
and it didn't stop those who got
de-platformed you know they kept saying
all these lefties deep platforming works
i'm like i'm sorry i seem to seem to
have remembered a ton of these deep
platform people at the u.s capitol
bull horning or marching and getting
tons of followers on just different
platforms
sure maybe shut down all of the internet
but we'll talk about this stuff and we
also got
luke kowski if we are changed i think
all of us in this room should stutter
music band that's called
not censored yet howdy hello i am your
fellow parking lot vendor and
humble t-shirt vendor and if you want to
support my efforts you can on we are
change.org forward slash shorts thanks
for having me
and you're also an independent
journalist yes everybody knows you at
this point ian's back
hi ian ian were you sick yeah i was i
had a headache
i think i stayed up too late we shouted
you out though we want to make sure
everybody followed you because
you know we need to free the code i've
been getting really nice tweets lately
yeah yeah look at that yeah yo i'm just
ready to get dirty
what does that mean let's roll around
the mud man i feel like we're we're
slathering ourselves in feces and
talking about how dirty it is
when we talk about this like gross you
know left versus right
all this junky like we're in it we're in
the darkness you know so let's just
you know wipe it on all over ourselves i
i i was thinking about what you were
saying about left versus right and i
feel like tribalist is a better word for
it
because like ocasio-cortez in my opinion
doesn't fairly represent the left
she's a tribalist it's like you know her
whole persona is owning the cons
so if you've got someone who's the whole
thing is owning the libs and someone on
the left who's owning the cons
i don't feel that as accurately
representing the actual values of a
liberal conservative or a socialist
or a traditionalist or whatever it's
just someone who wants to
pre like they use that as their stand to
earn internet points so i think you know
a lot of what we see on social media is
just tribalism
has nothing to do with your actual
political ideology it's which team are
you on yeah and that can change
right in the heat of the moment this is
a good point i mean people don't
uh realize with all this partisanship
and tribalism
how much the populist left and populist
right have in common especially in
foreign policy
uh and the tribalists get in the way
yeah because then you end up with the
left cheering for the establishment if
it means owning the cons
but we'll talk about all this don't
forget we got sarpatu let's press the
button i'm in the corner pushing buttons
and before we get started i'm gonna give
a shout out to today's sponsor
safe and ready meals my friends if you
go to safeandreadymeals.com
you can get 20 off emergency food
supplies
i know you know i've promoted this stuff
a lot uh fairly often over the past year
and
i'm a big fan actually we've we've been
eating it because it's you know
basically just
you mix it in the pot you put some water
in it but this stuff has a 25 year shelf
life up to
25 years and you can get like i
mentioned 25 percent off we got two week
emergency food and four week again
safeandrymeals.com
here's the thing uh i'm not telling
anybody become a prepper and go you know
dig a fort or whatever and stock it with
30 years of beans
i'm just my whole thing is we get
reports of floods and hurricanes and
it's always good to have some kind of
emergency supplies be it water food in a
first aid kit
it was always surprising to me that
people have first aid but they don't
have food when you literally have to eat
every day
well i guess you don't have to eat every
day but you eat a lot and you don't
really use it first aid kit all that
often so check it out
safeandreadymeals.com special thanks for
them to sponsor
a special thanks to them for sponsoring
the show but one more thing i want to
mention
for those of you who haven't already go
to teespring.com forward slash stores
forward slash tim cast and you will
notice right there in front
it says i am a gorilla many of you have
been posting incessantly in the in the
in the chat that you are in fact
gorillas so we have honored your wishes
and produced a shirt that says
i am a gorilla and it is a gorilla
grinning and you know
holding his fist together and we
actually have some more uh we have we
have a valentine's day one i'm a gorilla
love yourself
and then we're going to do a special
edition of the i am a gorilla shirt with
a tin foil hat on that
once we once it goes live it'll be only
available for probably a few days to get
but again teespring.com forward slash
stores that's what it has
slash tim cast and then you can see the
i am a gorilla shirt we'll get urls up
so it's easier to uh to find the stuff
but
for all of you who wanted that silly
gorilla shirt congratulations you can
now get it and it comes in a couple
colors
but let's get back to the news before we
get started smash the like button
subscribe
notification bell wow that was long
here's the news from the ap
donald trump's been impeached after
capital riot in historic
second charge again they say president
donald trump was impeached by the u.s
house for a historic second time
wednesday
charged with incitement of insurrection
over the deadly mob siege in the capital
in a swift and stunning collapse of his
final days in office
we get it several republicans actually
joined in there were 10 that's kind of
surprising but not too surprising
interestingly we heard that mitch
mcconnell was would not be calling
a special session of the senate which
means the actual trial for donald trump
will happen
will happen after biden is already
present president
but you need to understand there is one
thing they are doing here
before i tell you what that one thing is
i'll note donald trump put out a big
statement today on video on youtube for
the white house saying
no violence and no law breaking and if
you look back at what donald trump said
in dc he said
peacefully protest peacefully march to
cheer on politicians
he didn't tell anybody to do anything
direct or to storm the capital or any of
that stuff
but that's not what's important the
democrats are levying a charge of
incitement of insurrection
for one reason if trump is convicted
for insurrection that is grounds to
prevent him from running in 2024.
that's what they're after and that's why
they are now trying to
impeach him even though i'm sorry i'm
sorry they did impeach him
that's why they're hoping to convict him
even after he leaves office
so i've heard from a lot of people
they've said it's too late you'll never
get a senate trial in time what's the
point
there's many republicans who are like
why is only eight days left
because they don't want him to be able
to have any political power
ever again and they want to do the same
thing to all these other republicans who
supported trump
in the constitutional process of
objecting to the vote so i don't know
what you guys think but
uh i think it's doomed to fail unless
you think they're republicans who are
actually gonna you know they need 67
votes
i mean uh i mean who knows mcconnell
seems to really hate trump right now
uh who knows where that will go uh the
question is you know is uh is trump like
trump like the uh the obi-wan kenobi of
getting impeached every time you do it
he gets stronger
because he does have this image of you
know the one guy against everyone else
and this seems to bolster that image
yeah yeah the if you strike me down i'll
become more possible more powerful than
you could possibly imagine
that's that's the bigger question beyond
all of this though so i rolled my eyes
when it's like here we go with
impeachment again and they really
dragged it out
it was like they announced we're going
to impeach trump on monday and then on
monday they were like oh here we go
but we're going to give mike pence 24
hours
48 hours we're gonna impeach him on
wednesday and then they finally do it
didn't they need like nine months to
decide
that the average citizen gets 600 but
when it comes to impeachment they could
just do it like that i mean
it you know this is a major thing but i
feel like it's losing its lackluster
it was such a major big deal with bill
clinton when he was impeached he still
obviously was
able to be president but but now it's
like okay we get the kind of larger
symbolic gestures and i feel like
there's a lot of them
that essentially don't really amount to
a lot what the gestures
well the the larger kind of uh saying
you know trump's out
you know trying to just to push anything
trump out like
we saw the golf course we saw new york
city also announced today that they're
getting that they're
getting rid of any contracts they had
with trump including uh his property in
the bronx including his ice skating rink
in central park so we're seeing just
a lot of people using this situation to
kind of stand on the grave of donald
trump saying look how good i am
by dumping trump and that's crazy
because trump's popular still
like the trump supporters still love the
man just because he's out of prison he's
not president anymore doesn't mean
they're going to sit by and just
let these people destroy everything
trump i think him getting banned
made people love him like he got all
this sympathy after he got banned off
twitter
because the people were ready to start
hating on him and now all of a sudden
well you know what it is
i think the trump reply guys and these
journalists on the left are sweating
bullets
like you're going to get laid off jim
acosta's already gone
you guys saw that right no what happened
cnn announced that jim acosta is no
longer the white house you know
correspondent
he served his purpose well you can look
it that way or you can just look at it
as
jim acosta was doing a job for cnn
but without trump he's literally nothing
the it's he served his purpose i think
sounds too nice
it's that jim acosta doesn't have
anything going for him the only thing he
had was that he was the guy who was
willing to waste everyone's time
just blabbering at trump and not ask
actually asking questions
i'll be the first breitbart reporter
accused of being too nice to jim acosta
no but it is you served your person
purpose and you can go and i'm like well
well well
he was useless from the get-go until
trump came in yes no for real
that's better actually yeah yeah i mean
did anyone know jim acosta before trump
nope no i mean i i think i don't even
know what he was doing for cnn he was
the white house press corps for a while
i remember meeting him
um oddly enough at bilderberg but he
wasn't covering bilderberg he was just
staying at the bilderberg hotel before
the actual conference was happening
and that's where i actually met him and
um so so what you're saying he actually
got fired
uh if he was the white house
correspondent before
trump this was years and years ago um
and uh i gotta i gotta look up the dates
to verify it but he was the white house
correspondent
yeah he was the white house uh
correspondent for a while they gave him
a boot you see
they're shutting down their airport
network yes cnn airport is gone they're
just because without
trump they're in panic yeah and you know
jeff zucker the president of cnn was
like you know what the
it's the lack of air travel from you
know because of covid and the changing
way people are consuming media and i'm
like
yeah but what about cnn hotels like
hotels play cnn all the time
but i guess they were paying the airport
so that makes sense that they would
terminate
that i wonder what the airports are
going to do oh no they're just going to
leave cnn on i think that's actually a
bet cnn probably made
i mean they have all these tvs the
airports airports aren't going to just
turn them off don't have to play
something
wasn't there rumors about zucker
potentially leaving cnn 2 recently
yeah yeah yeah yep okay the the whole
ecosystem the whole
economic system of the media was built
on donald trump for four years
that's why i've been saying before the
media secretly wants trump to win
but they can't say it or contribute to
it but deep down
they're like what am i gonna do like
there's an op-ed from one journalist
freaking out being like my whole career
was built on calling out trump and now
he's gone what do i do
and it was like some other journalist
talking them down like calm down calm
down
you'll figure it out you'll you'll
evolve from this i was surprised to see
the krasenstein brothers uh celebrating
uh in a short video
if if you don't know that they're two
guys who the only people
the only reason anyone knows their name
is because they were trump reply guys on
twitter
they got their following through
responding to donald trump they were
celebrating him getting banned well you
know
that's how you that's how people know
who you are
but this whole thing about corporate
corporations banks cutting off trump
social media companies cutting off trump
it's kind of a silver lining in a way
because it shows where power lies
in america and it's raised this issue
now i think to international concern
you've got foreign leaders
who are horrified to see i was i was
really uh um
uh what's the right word uh not shocked
i was
impressed you know to see bastions of
human rights and civil liberties
standing up
just give gave me hope you know like
like uh china and
uganda calling out these these horrific
acts that were being carried
out in the united states bravo well one
thing that's really interesting is that
there is
international outrage about what's
happening in the united states with the
banning of the us president on social
media kind of transferring the power of
information into the small hands of a
few
select billionaires and it's a few
french ministers
angela merkel uh the mexican president
and and a lot of other people
are actually australian ministers as
well and the reports the british prime
minister is now considering uh
regulations on tax censorship now this
is interesting yeah this is interesting
because
we don't hear about this at all like
there's no outcry there's celebration on
social media that were shown
on mainstream media which calls for more
heads to roll
uh but but we don't hear any of the
legitimate concerns that are are very
serious i mean we're living in a
situation where
essentially a few people have total
control they privatize
the internet and they could do whatever
they want with this vast
ever growing power that has so much
influence on our lives and it's
absolutely scary
people outside of the us are realizing
it and
no one's even hearing about it yeah so
american elites love the fact that these
tech companies can stamp down on their
political opponents
but uh no one in any other country
really likes the idea of that because
they don't want an american
they don't want an american company
coming and picking and choosing their
elected leaders
chancellor of germany doesn't want that
the prime minister doesn't want that the
dictator of uganda doesn't want that he
just banned
twitter and facebook before his election
well they understand this kind of bigger
merger of big
tech and the biden administration that's
hiring all these tech executives to be a
part of its government
this merger is going to have vast power
not just in the united states but
specifically the world
whenever there's a protest whenever
there's a demonstration whenever there's
a world leader that doesn't play along
that doesn't do whatever the elites want
him to do whatever the billionaire class
wants done if if they don't do it if
they don't jump when they say jump
they're going to have all the power in
the world to shut someone down
everywhere because of their speech and
and we have to understand this is not
just twitter facebook
these are monopoly powers of amazon and
google that
control the key infrastructures of our
information highways
so whether it's server space whether
it's internet cables
these people have so much power way
beyond
just social media algorithms so it's
interesting poland
they announced this bill if you i don't
know if you guys saw this yes where
they're gonna
you know reign in big tech i actually
have this uh the story from new york
post written by will chamberlain
he writes poland appropriately enough is
leading the way
their justice minister zigbernu
announced last month the polish
government would enact a law
constraining big tech from censoring
their citizens
polish users who are victims of
censorship can go to a new polish court
get an injunction forcing the company to
restore their account and their content
on penalty of a fine of as much as 1.8
million euro
we should do the same americans should
have the same right to speak on large
social media platforms
that they do in a public park we simply
need to change the law
to make that a reality you know i love
the most about this here i am you know
10 years ago uh fundraising and doing
you know engaging in activism
to regulate major corporations why oil
spills
big political lobbying violation of
civil liberties
and you know you have these big evil
companies
and here i am today doing the exact same
thing now weird yet now
conservatives have joined in and it's
really interesting to see the left has
abandoned me
where'd they go they no longer want to
regulate the companies that are seizing
the commons
i made an analogy to this on twitter
where i said i
had an epiphany after being told but my
private company for the 500 millionth
time
and i realized that all the activism i
did for the environment was wrong
bp is a private company if they want if
they have if they build an oil rig in
the ocean and they're permitted to do it
and oil spills out of it
well too bad why don't you start a
company to clean up that oil
and i know of course they all said
that's a different thing it's a
different problem that doesn't make
sense i said it certainly makes sense
bp cause damage to the commons the areas
that we all share
that must be protected so that people
can use them in that
destruction and damage we all got mad
and there are regulations to protect
prevent them from doing this
what i see with big tech and social
media is them
shutting down legal political speech in
the commons where we have our
they've taken over the town square
people aren't going out and going to
church to talk anymore they're not going
to community centers they're doing it on
twitter
and the big tech companies shut that
down and i believe they need to be
regulated in some capacity and this
sounds like a good solution
allow people to get an injunction well
this latest news definitely made me feel
more
polish and proud from my home country
but we have to understand europe has
been taking a very different approach
than the united states when it comes to
big tech for
a long time when it comes to regulations
fines and penalties
social media has been kind of pushed
back there more than
i would say anywhere else in the world
but also specifically with poland and
other countries like hungary
i also recently saw an article saying
that the biden administration
is eyeing poland and hungary to get back
at it for some of the kind of
close relations that they had previously
with donald trump
and because of their implementation of
policies that don't go along
with of course the the kind of global
order that the people want to push the
global reset
immigration uh you know nationalism
those are key important issues that
poland and hungary hold
close to their heart that of course is
different than the rest of europe and
that's why we're seeing
the biden administration kind of set its
eyes on that specific region because
they're going to be implementing
policies that are going to affect it in
very negative ways and you especially
see this with hungary where you had the
state department actually funding
opposition media in hungary the reason
why they particularly dislike that
country
is because hungary is trying to get the
ngos out of the country
the ngos are of course arms of u.s
influence abroad they're all funded by
usaid or the state department didn't
they ban
sorrows they banned thesaurus ngos yes
it was quite a while ago
you know it's interesting i think you
were telling me something luke because
uh i grew up
in amsterdam chicago in a very polish
neighborhood
and of course there's always the
stereotype about polish people not being
smart
you mentioned that it was because the
soviet union executed the intelligentsia
of poland
yes well when russia came in they
they took a lot of the professionals
whether doctors whether professors
teachers and they executed a lot of them
or sent some of them to siberia in order
to gain
cultural control of larger institutions
that they were
able to implement communism that the
polish people hated and they resisted
and and that's one of the reasons why
this kind of labeling by the russians as
polls as being stupid
uh is kind of prevalent but also if you
look at it
polish people actually have a very high
iq especially compared to that region
but but specifically it didn't work but
but another thing i want to bring up
because i saw a tweet i don't know
exactly who said this but it was by a
left-wing verified user talking about
how
he wants to make sure that trump
supporters can't ever be teachers
uh professors uh and any kind of
workers that have any kind of work that
has kind of um
powers to be a boss or to influence yes
i don't know the exact tweet so i don't
want to mention it
you know directly but but we're seeing
kind of similar epithets
being issued by blue checkmark verified
twitter users that are worrying
and that do echo some other historical
uh
timelines that are troublesome and john
brennan saying that no no one who served
in the trump administration should ever
get a job anywhere else it reminds me of
uh debartification in iraq yeah
anyone who's part of the bath party you
can't let them do anything
that's literally what we were talking
about yesterday that brought onto the
onset of isis that was one of the key
moves according to many strategists that
brought
isis to the national stage was that
particular move that you brought up
sorry go ahead tim
i was gonna say i think the the the
thing you were saying about poland is
really interesting because
yeah they want to get rid of the
intelligent the intelligentsia the
thought leaders the cultural leaders
in poland and we're seeing a similar
thing with mass censorship
they want to take out the influential
people of you know right-wing populism
and at the same time what you see with
poland is a deep
hatred for communism and fascism or
nazism because they were oppressed by
both
so now you have this country that's like
we're going to defend the right of our
citizens because we know exactly what it
leads to
regardless of your le if you're left
wing or right wing
i remember seeing a meme recently and it
said dangerous tools
of uh insurrection and it had a guitar
and it had a paintbrush and and we have
to understand here the bigger cultural
aspects and institutions are pretty much
more and more political for a reason and
they're extorting a lot of that power a
lot of that kind of culture a lot of
that kind of
influence in ways that really should
make people question what's really going
on here
but you can tell how the tech company is
really messed up because it's not just
poland and hungary who have been opposed
to inaudible for a while and poland was
working on this
before the trump bands uh still was
hungary but it's also alarmed germany
and france and the uk and australia
because you know all of those countries
you know they run by fairly you know
neo-liberal or left-wing governments
especially germany
and they have hate speech laws on the
books uh
but they look at what silicon valley is
doing and and are thinking well hold on
it's our job to define what hate speech
is that's a job of our national
parliaments our governments
we're not going to have silicon valley
coming and set the rules for us yeah
many people don't understand
in large parts of europe if you utter
some words together you literally will
end up
in jail there's people who just said
particular sounds
they are in jail we in the united states
have an amazing
right that's inherent for i think
everyone
to be able to exercise our free speech
but again
that is directly under threat right now
with all the major avenues of
communication
squashing down and making sure people
can't have a voice online well this is
an interesting question because is it
are the government consequences worse
now than the corporate consequences in
america
so at least in the in europe you know
when the state defines hate speech
that's governed by some form of
parliamentary procedure there's a
democratic process it's transparent they
can't just change it overnight
and they can't apply it arbitrarily has
to apply to everyone according to the
law
and there's accountability in a court
proceeding that happens sorry go ahead
indeed
and where a silicon valley they can
change it overnight they can apply it to
just to one set of people and not to
another
uh and uh the consequences can
potentially be more severe you could
lose your entire livelihood your entire
business
whereas in europe mostly you might get a
fine uh it was count
for the right to go like an 800 pound
fine is that worse than being
demonetized and by youtube i think
anything demonetizes worse but
following the arrest and the smears he
did get that as well you know it was it
was an arrest
it was a charge it was you know criminal
trial and then silicon valley piles
exactly exactly i'll tell you what's
scarier than twitter banning someone
what's scary is banks banning people or
vendors banning people
what we're seeing now is one of the most
dis look
i'll say the word dystopian nightmarish
all that stuff
but let me just stress this point we're
at we are in this
space now where almost every corporation
is terrified of everyone walking in
lockstep
and banning any wrong thinker it doesn't
matter if there's a government doing it
it doesn't there's no this is this is
scarier there's no head to this hydra
or the snake it is literally a chicken
with no head running around freaking out
and so you'll get so uh there was there
was a tweet where some guy
was applying for a company they found
out that he was a trump supporter and he
had
actively supported trump you know quite
heavily so they were just like they
fired him
that's where we're headed we're headed
to where the company will say something
like
look man i honestly i voted for the guy
but you know the activists
so we we can't hire you and then you see
what happens to parlor what you see
you see what the ceo of parlor just said
he doesn't think parlo's coming back
it may never return wow yep because no
one will work with them
and the left says see the free market
i'm like it's a really good point about
the problems of a free market
in that there could be an ideology
behind whether or not anyone would do
business with you
i mean i would argue i guess
philosophically a free market is free
from
over overarching ideologies that would
you know impede or shut down
but where we're at now it is worse it is
the mexican standoff of cancer culture
every single person now whether they
like it or not
are scared about what will happen there
are companies that i know
that are i should say i have i have
friends who are associated with certain
companies
they like trump or they love trump or
they're neutral and don't care but they
all recognize if anyone finds out
we'll lose everything why because
everyone is scared of everyone else
no one knows who's gonna be the person
to raise the pitchfork why are you
scared of these people
the only way that stops if people say i
don't care you can yell on the internet
so what i mean john stuart mill talked
about the tyranny of the majority where
uh everyone sort of behaves in a way and
you know clamps down
but this is less tyranny of the majority
because i think if you ask the majority
of people
do you think you know people who support
trump should be able to have jobs i mean
i think most people would agree with
that this is the kind it's tyranny of
heard behavior
right of a very specific group of people
who are in power and all believe this
but it's a very small group of people
who just happen to be running all the
corporations
yeah it is people scared of being called
a racist
and so they're like but if i serve this
person then they'll call me a racist
so what god just grow up man i can't
believe that there are businesses that
were like we can't do we can't work with
you parlor we're scared
yeah that's pathetic and you know what
this is on conservatives too you have to
vote with your dollars
do not support anybody who would bow and
bend to this
herd uh you know what did you call it
her tyranny
yeah tyranny of the hurt behavior right
we can't we we can't do this if
someone's gonna bend the knee to a bunch
of screaming people
then we're not gonna be able to function
all right so you need to be able to run
your business
and stand up for what you believe in and
yet the problem is i think
republicans the political party is a
spineless
massive there's i'm sorry spineless is
not fair it's a bowl of spaghetti it's a
bunch of wet noodles flopping around in
congress
who for years knew this problem existed
and you know and i said in 2018 i said
republicans are too
stupid to know you know to sol to
they're too stupid to address the
problem of big tech censorship
and that's the politicians there are
some people who have consistently
brought
republicans who have brought forth bills
challenging this calling out big tech
my respect to them but most of them have
just been flopping around like wet
noodles doing whatever they're told
then you end up with someone like jared
kushner brad parscale tells donald trump
get on parlor get on a different
platform and then trump says what do you
think
to jared and kushner goes nah don't do
it and trump goes
okay and now here you are now hold on
trump's lucky
because while he may not have had the
understanding or experience
to actually solve this and was getting
bad advice from people like kushner
other people saw it coming and lo and
behold
gab.com has archived and backed up the
real donald trump account
verified 1.2 million followers and all
of his tweets up to the point
i think there's some tweets that are
missing but for the most part his entire
account
is here with videos and statements and
at any point trump could just use it
now my question is right now why isn't
trump using it
why doesn't he still just go on use gab
there it is well he'd overload the site
for sure because they're using
their own infrastructure but at a
certain point trump
should just okay i'll use whatever
platform i can he's one of those stupid
republicans man
[Laughter]
i think trump's old and he's and and i
don't even know if he
there actually i'll tell you this there
was a donald trump schedule post went
out i don't know if it was real
but it said something like trump is
going to be working very very hard he'll
be working all day
working very hard having many meetings
yeah phone calls
and people are like did trump write this
like it sounds just like he wrote it
yeah did you saw that i did so so maybe
it's just that he doesn't have any
advice anymore
and he's just not talking to anybody and
he's sitting around like i don't know
was it written in sharpie because it was
that was him and we'll have many many
meetings and phone calls
but this is this is great what gab did
because even if you don't like the
president or if you like the president
this is an important historical record
where major events unfolded on that
twitter account that
are historically relevant so i mean the
bigger question that you
you kind of mentioned here what's
stopping him i don't think anything
should be i think he should be using
any kind of platform that promotes free
speech
he just did this this statement saying
like no violence and all that but he
also said i want to call out
the the big tech censorship well bro
just go ahead and get on gab
yeah go on yeah get on gab there you go
i mean
that there needs to be industry-wide
reform to a number of industries
including banking including
credit cards including big tech because
you can't have the situation where
you've got a two-tiered society where
some people have access to the economy
and some people don't
but i will say gab.com is the one
example of build your own actually
working
because they had many many challenges
they lost their web host they lost their
dns registrar
but they overcame all that they built
their own servers they're building their
own phones
they're building their own phones
they've got their own web browser
servers
i mean they're having trouble handling
the traffic right now they've got a huge
search they're built
bringing more servers online but you
know they're still up and running they
haven't taken them out
although i will say just today we're
seeing that now the desperation
of uh the people who don't want internet
freedom the anti-defamation league
has petitioned the the justice
department to launch a criminal
investigation into gab
for hosting violent content well there
you go see now they're trying to
get into the criminal realm but we got a
constitution we'll see how that plays
out
now here's where it gets real real scary
hbs hsbc
says customers who refuse to wear a face
mask
will have their accounts withdrawn the
lender reiterated the face masks are
mandatory in all branches
unless legally exempt warning customers
that non-compliance could result in
accounts being closed
now that is where things start getting
worrisome now look look
i i got no problem wearing a mask i
really don't care i don't know people
really don't like it they want to defy
it i get it
some people really are medically exempt
but the issue is
not so much about you know but they
should wear a mask you know it's an
issue of when you threaten someone's
access to the economy in general
when we're already a point where like 99
of all currency
is digital and not even physical that
people would
lose their right to bank that that
cancel
why do we not have national banks what's
going on why do we have private banks
all over the place it's crazy
i mean there's problems with national
banks too at least the government can
control them
and that's us we have the opportunity to
control them and say no you can't censor
you think
american citizens that's us you think
you could petition nancy pelosi to do
something
it's a big problem because we're in a
situation where these private companies
uh we need to protect ourselves we need
to use our government i'm not a huge
fan of using the government but in this
case we have global
private companies that are threatening
our sovereignty and we need to use our
government
to protect us right but not national
banks probably a regulation
like well good news on this one of the
good things that uh trump did right
uh just in the past few months was an
order from the office of the comptroller
of the currency which is an officer
didn't know existed
but they uh put out a uh regulation
against d banking i'm not sure if it's
gone through yet they were doing the
whole notice and comment period
where they were taking in feedback from
the public but it specifically said
uh people have been trying to use banks
for political reasons
to uh to withdraw service from the gun
industry
uh from private prisons and this new
rule essentially says that if you're
going to withdraw service to someone it
must be because of financial risk
so you know because of defaulted loans
or uh or you know
the the normal reasons why you wouldn't
but
that's good there still is the problem
that there are
attacks that activists do where they use
fraudulent cards to cause massive
chargebacks and massive fraud you know
that's what happened to gab actually
that is a problem yeah well what's next
if you don't bend the knee your bank
account's going to be deleted i mean
it's absolutely ridiculous i already did
it and
that's that's that was my next point
there's a large number of people that
had
their bank accounts taken away because
of their political opinion
and when we look at hsbc they don't have
the best reputation themselves
if you remembered at occupy wall street
me and you actually met uh hsbc
whistleblower we actually talked about
even doing a bigger story with another
news organization about that
that exposed uh we were the we were the
first story that kind of broke it how
hsbc helped terrorist
iran mexican drug cartels launder money
and that was another huge issue about
this
you know a record of this company that
did awful things now lecturing us about
what is right and good for you i mean
it's just ridiculous
i'm not going to take their advice
seriously because they don't get to
choose what i do in my own personal life
well look i think
i need to change my bank account so hsbc
in the us and in the uk
look if if there's a physical building
it's privately owned and they say you
have to wear a mask
the extent to what their powers should
be is please leave until you have a mask
on
that's it banking needs some kind of
protections look man
i i have uh it's remarkable that i've
always been in favor of
of curtailing map power be it government
or
corporate power so i'm in favor of
regulations i'm in favor of leveraging
government against corporations that are
too big too powerful
especially individuals who would use
that power and access to manipulate the
political sphere
because if we don't deal with that and
perhaps it's too late
you know i've heard this you know in the
past decade or so from the left that
it's too late
to actually make a difference because we
are a what what
remember that citibank report you guys
remember this back in like it was during
occupy wall street
they said the us the us government is no
longer a democratic republic
or a constitutional republic it is a
plutonomy where the ruling class of
elites and wealthy control everything
and there was a study that showed that
public perception and public opinion had
no impact at all on legislation
none and that the impact was the
opinions of lobbyists and the wealthy
elites
that's what occupy wall street was upset
with
and you know what's interesting i
actually think donald trump
is the evolution of occupy wall street
in many ways don't get me wrong bernie
sanders
was some of it it's like occupy split a
little bit then he went to bernie
interestingly though once bernie sold
out went full-on establishment
he retained a lot of those people from
occupy probably because their issues
during occupy was more
i don't know social justice but a lot of
the people who supported trump
were many of them were occupy wall
street uh activists
i remember i was at the deplorable when
you know just before trump was getting
inaugurated
and there were people there who saw me
and they're like hey we're big fans and
i was like
wow trump supporters you know big fans
of mine and they're like oh yeah we
were we were big occupy wall street
activists and i was like
really and they're like oh yeah this is
why trump won in 2016 because he called
out the uh the
plutonomy they do kill something we said
there's a class of global elites that
get away with everything and run
everything you don't really have a
democratic republican anymore he's
basically saying the same thing that was
in that report
yeah there's also a lot of occupy wall
street people who are like burn it all
down
let's vote for him let's vote against
establishment
and another thing specifically
connecting occupy wall street and hsbc
there was a huge
backlash against the banks specifically
hsbc for this money laundering
where they ended up paying a 1.9 billion
dollar
fine in 2012 for that horrible action
that they were caught with their parents
on the laundry for drug cartels uh so
and again they found their cudgel bro
yeah so they can get away
with the worst atrocities these big
corporations man i love it
these big corporations disney the the
thanking the uh the paramilitary group
in in was it jinjang where the the
weaker muslims are in concentration
thank you for for helping us produce
this movie
and then they can come out with all
their social justice narratives and
statements and everyone just rolls with
it
you know what i think the reality is
though they got their useful idiots
they got their their personalities who
hate trump and and just want to own the
cons and all that stuff
i think most people get it though i
think i think
most people understand there's a problem
with big corporations
unfortunately many of them got wrapped
up in trump derangement syndrome
because the the the strategy from the
you know major media and these companies
works
you just keep screaming black lives
matter is okay and then
you you blame the trump supporters for
everything and when that narrative
is just repeated over and over and over
what ends up happening is you've got
people who only watch mainstream news
and every every version of a trump
supporter they see
is the angry loud spitting disrespectful
lunatic
and they don't see a regular person you
know they don't see a
will chamberlain for instance we just
referenced one of his articles suit
wearing lawyer
calm very vanilla they don't see that uh
excuse me
okay dressed up for this appearance but
right but like you could you could go to
uh you know i was just
i was just out shopping and the the lady
you know at the store she's like a trump
supporter and she's a regular low low
ladies like you know serving baked goods
they see the tv they live in big cities
so they don't encounter very many trump
supporters and if they do
those people won't admit it so they
don't realize it and they watch the
cnn and they just rag on trump all day
and night and then they're told all the
riots are good and that shapes their
world view and they don't realize
i think you mentioned it earlier that
the left and the right populists agree
on
a lot more than they disagree on
but it's it's an excellent way to get
away with
slave labor and concentration camps
because all they got to do is put out
their little commercial where they're
like we're for social justice and then
you know put a rainbow flag
and they and that's it no outrage no
media uh you know
complaints and it really does come down
to you know where you stand on the woke
stuff where do you stand on critical
race theory or feminism or something
that's what divides
a lot of people and you know some people
you know theorize that corporation
support woke stuff for precisely this
reason
i don't agree with that i think they
genuinely believe this stuff but
uh it's inconsequential at the end of
the day
and uh this is what allows the sort of
uniparty to maintain power
you know you know what i hear what
you're saying and i've just had a
realization i've been wrong this whole
time
the woke stuff is good it's great
ian did you know the federal federal
reserve is run by old white men
well let's burn it down then no no no no
no we need to get the old white man
out and diversify the federal reserve we
need new rules new regulations
and we need hard oversight to make sure
that all of the people who are sitting
in seats of power at the federal reserve
are no longer there anymore because
they're white men down with the
patriarch down with the patriarchy all
right we're all in agreement everybody
agrees
that uh the banking system is run by old
white men which it is and therefore
we need diversity in the bank no don't
use evil to accomplish your goals
kidding the joke is i i'm curious
because we did
mention this the other day like where is
anyone to just be like
screw it okay i'm down with the wokeness
hey look the military industrial complex
is a bunch of white people too
well that's that's like using evil to
accomplish your goals that's
part of the problem with using fascism
to get trump out of office to to use
social media
right it's like you can't you shouldn't
use evil and use
fascism to defeat your enemy because it
doesn't work it's it it defeats your
enemy but it keeps fascism
yeah it might destroy your enemy but
you're gonna create what you use
the system you use so if you're using
hatred you know you're just gonna
like you know i was i was thinking about
uh the banking systems and all this
stuff
and how really weird it is that it's
just numbers typed in a computer and
then a ledger keeping track of it
and that's it that's all the money
system really is it's the it's it's
powerful elites who run the banks who
decide who has access to resources
it's essentially what we have now in
this in this centralized banking system
is a way to control absolute power
in a country or countries while
convincing people that they're
you know voting in democratic
institutions and the other way to
control them is of course the uh the
tech giants now that's how you control
communication
and that's why they'll crush all any and
all competition
that's why parlor was just obliterated
if trump
in the middle of the night without
saying a word to anyone signed up for
parlor and then posted
trump is here they would not have been
able to have banned parlor it would have
been too
much too many people would have known it
would have been a major story and it
would have been too much
no i think they would have done i don't
think they really cared i think that
might have even
made them more determined to cross
parties i disagree i think the story
would have been
it would have been too much for the
average person to see that they
annihilated an entire social network
because trump joined it
they got rid of parlor before trump
joined it and they used bs reasons they
you know amazon said we don't believe
you'll be effective in your moderation
what does that even mean how do you
break a contract on what you believe
might happen is it as bad what could
they do that would be worse than letting
hang mike pence trend which is what
twitter did or the fact now that it's
it's starting to come out
the the capital uh riots was was
organized
on facebook glenn greenwald reported
that first and now face was going uh
well actually how do you answer for that
yeah and there's even fbi reports of
a supposed war coming to the capitol
with them knowing that there was a major
clash point happening there
that they chose to what looks like
ignore and nothing was really done about
it
at all so that's yet another kind of
thing to really kind of consider here
moving forward
facebook is responsible i mean it's not
surprising
you know if you want to defend facebook
by all means you can go ahead and do it
it's the biggest platform everybody use
it so of course they're gonna use their
organizing tools
the problem i have isn't to blame
facebook because they exist
problem i have is the concerted effort
from silicon valley to crush any
any rivals using fake reasons like
saying parlor
had extremist content and they were
organizing on parlor well as the ceo of
parlor pointed out
we have no organizing system there's no
way to organize events on parlor
facebook has events and groups parlor
doesn't it doesn't make sense
and amazon claimed that they didn't
believe the moderation would work why
because the reality was parlor was
removing the threats and the violence
they were doing exactly as they were
supposed to exactly as their rule stated
and getting rid of illegal content so
amazon had to say
well we don't think future moderation
will be effective because the reality
was current moderation was
and that's how they justify crushing it
and then what happens is
you know it you have these useful idiots
sycophants it's like
you guys ever watched that cartoon
recess you ever see that
you remember recess it's about the kids
in the school inside recess and there's
like
uh i can't remember the the old nasty
teacher's name and she was really mean
to the kids
and she had this little hunchback kid
who was like her henchmen who would
always do what she wanted
that's journalism awesome that's
journalism right it's like
it's like igor they're like hobbling
next to the establishment elites of the
corporations
yes hillary tell me what to do democrats
yes you're a bad guy you're a bad guy
tell me that i'm doing a good job
democrats
that's the media yeah the media has
really been an engine of big tech
censorship even more than the tech
companies themselves i think
because every time a tech company wasn't
censoring enough
wasn't doing it fast enough or whatever
you'd have this huge media campaign to
start an ad boycott they did that to
youtube with the adpocalypse
they did it to facebook just last summer
because they weren't censoring enough of
donald trump's ads
so they've tech companies have to deal
with that ever-present threat if they
don't play
ball the media will start uh an ad
boycott well that's even according to
alexandria ocasio-cortez with her
statement today that who's saying that
you know social media companies aren't
censoring enough of speech and she
quote wants to reign in the media to
stop the spread of disinformation those
are her words that she used af
you know today as of course she was also
calling for the banning of parlor she
was also suggesting putting trump
supporters on lists so they could be
quote held accountable for their actions
and
again when we look at alexandria
ocasio-cortez she's kind of this kind of
thought leader of the left that's very
popular that's always promoted always
pushed but she's pushing for some of the
worst authoritarian draconian measures
that you could
ever imagine and for some reason no one
is even questioning it or
or trying to say hey this is not because
they're scared of antifa
not look listen you know antifa has
created a culture
of mainstream establishment protection
to where it's it's it's like we were
saying about these businesses that fall
in line and ban parlor because they're
scared
cnn msnbc will defend auntie for why
because they're terrified of them
that's why when you saw that msnbc guy
whatever his name was standing in front
of a building with like 50 foot tall
flames and he goes it's mostly peaceful
why
he who's standing around these people
could you imagine what would happen if
you walked into a crowd of antifa and
black lives matter who are burning down
buildings and said
these violent lunatics are destroying
buildings and setting fire they'd be
like
shut them down they were trying to
obfuscate it when rioters were
rioting and breaking into the cnn
building in atlanta
they're like oh yeah it was so it was so
amazing to see the perplexing reporting
that was happening
when they were getting attacked in their
own headquarters and and they were just
having the most
difficult time time trying to break down
what was happening here look man this is
the problem that conservatives and trump
supporters have
it is it is the the powerful
establishment elites are dangling keys
in front of the trump supporters
in the direction of political
institutions
and that's what the trump supporters are
looking at meanwhile
upstream where the politics comes from
the culture the left has already taken
over
and they're using that against trump
supporters so when they when the trump
supporters go to the capitol
everyone says that's you know horrible
why would you do that but when the left
goes with pitchforks to
you know big tack to silicon valley to
the universities and spray paints things
on the walls and starts fires and burns
on whole cities
well that scares everybody into getting
whipped into line
i would say i don't know well it was
andrew breitbart who said politics is
downstream from cult culture right
the question is how do you change that
how do you change the culture when they
have control over the
institutions the education system
hollywood now the big tech companies
the algorithms the algorithms so i mean
the internet was helping for a while
uh i was saying you know that the one uh
foothold that conservatives have in
culture
every single meme that millennials use
probably came from 4chan or right at one
of these very politically incorrect
places
right but now they're shutting the
internet off as well now reddit is
very far left oh yeah reddit is now but
also not always not always right it used
to be
it used to be free-for-all yeah and they
purged everything the number one post on
reddit that i saw today was a picture of
charlie kirk
saying that he's a domestic terrorist
everyone upvotes this if you agree he's
a domestic terrorist and it reached
number one on all right and it was
shocking seeing the comments because
there's a lot of trump supporters that
don't like charlie kirk
yeah and he's he's he's more of the
establishment kind of rhino republican
and not even the kind of
outsider that a lot of people expect him
to be what i do like is i'll go on
reddit sometimes
and there will be uh uh a charlie kirk
meme where they make his face really
small
and that's funny though like making fun
of somebody and you're like whatever
it's like okay
it's a funny meme his face shrinks as
the more he says conservative things
but when they say domestic terrorist
when they say threat to our safety
that's the kind of inflammatory rhetoric
that leads to real world violence
i'm not saying they can't say it don't
get me wrong because i believe in free
speech
i'm just saying they shouldn't be going
out claiming that the right is engaging
in violent hate speech
when it's literally what they do the
crazy thing about it is
the dominant like you know the front
page of red at the top of all it's
dominated by like four like three
different ocasio-cortez
profiles all they do is repost aoc's
tweets and then upload them straight to
the top
right that's what the donald got banned
for
and now here we are with the exact same
problem which shows
the people who ran reddit it's funny
because i used to i used to know them i
used to hang i've been
i used to hang out their offices every
so often a couple times not like a whole
lot
and they used to just be very much you
know what people like they like what
they have what they upload
and then i guess they're in a city and
you had
you know let me let me tell you
something i talked to some very powerful
democratic donors
who are looking at ways to create apps
that would
function like social media platforms and
would would actually be
like campaign tools like the idea at
first this is a long time it was like
2014.
they were like how do we create an app
for the campaign that functions like
reddit
and so i had con meetings with people
and they never really went anywhere
and then to see what's happened now with
the with the astroturfing of a place
like reddit
if you post a conservative opinion or
even a moderate one you're obliterated
you're gone your comment doesn't exist
everything is dominated by the left but
the extremist tribal left
it's not even about this is why that's
why i said earlier it's tribalism it's
not even about economic policy
like think about if i came for and i
said i believe we should have more
progressive tax brackets
they'd be like well you're far right in
what capacity is that
doesn't matter because it's tribalism
has nothing to do with what your
politics are
it has to do with who you align with
that's like the uh the tribalist is like
the
it's like the distant hand of the
control of the culture which is the rich
people
it's the money and it has been for
probably since the beginning of time
since the creation of currency or wealth
in general
used to be gold it was salt and then in
the 70s they turned it into fiat so now
it's just whoever has the most
numbers in their bank account but now
there's this for the last 50 years it's
been such a mind
f screw that like people don't know who
who controls the culture and there's
like this
this this combat conflict at the top
and now there's cryptocurrency appearing
but it's the rich people that are
controlling the culture which then
heads down to politics and they're using
these tribalist
ventures to god forbid create
war but i think maybe like the great
reset
and they really want the united states
to fight itself because it's it's
standing in the way of like a socialist
the dictatorship the problem is where
power actually lies in society has been
kind of concealed for a while people
still think that you know the senate or
the house of representatives is really
important that's really just political
theater
just look at how they behave with the
tech giants right they bring them in for
hearings
every few months and then do absolutely
nothing after the hearings
most power now now are lies in the
federal bureaucracy political power
anyway
and the rest of the power lies as we've
seen in the tech giants with the banks
with the corporations
i think it's almost like the elections
i've often felt have been pointless
and only after donald trump won did i go
like well
you know maybe voting is it doesn't
matter like wow i can't believe trump
won
but now i still feel very similarly
trump won and so what
no honestly look he won the republicans
were in power they didn't do anything
they didn't give they didn't help trump
at all
they just sit on their hands and i think
it's basically what you said
it's it's it's almost like they're uh
you know like queen elizabeth everybody
loves her you know
in the uk but what does she do she is
the head of state but they say her role
is mostly ceremonial
she does have the executive authority
right to like override and make these
yeah but she's never very but she never
does and that's what i feel like we have
now
when you watch that hearing where ted
cruz he's like you're censoring
conservatives and it's like that's right
ted you tell him that
afterwards what are you gonna do yeah
what are you gonna do now again there
are some republicans who have presented
bills to do stuff and then no one
sponsored them they'll get voted on they
don't go anywhere
so it's almost kind of just ceremonial
at this point yeah are you guys prequel
fans
the star wars prequels remember how in
the in the phantom menace
the phantom menace somehow got politics
right okay because
the entire first half of the movie is
about
the queen of the planet who's just been
invaded trying to get to the republic
senate and make her case
and when she and when she gets there uh
she's asked for she's
they demand more proof of this so-called
invasion
and the chancellor says well he'll have
a committee discuss it right right so
somehow they got american politics right
there that was a perfect allegory
i think what you said about the kind of
corporate elite being in charge is
absolutely true
and when we really look at it it's it's
not just a corporate elite it's a
corporate banking billionaire elite
that's absolutely unaccountable
and commits some of the worst human
atrocities that they're they're never
held accountable for whether it's
monsanto
bp coca-cola nike they have a horrendous
record of abuse of civil rights of
of human rights abuses that deserve to
be addressed and yet they're lecturing
us about how we should live our lives
they're lecturing us about social
justice it's absolutely absurd but
they're becoming more emboldened
with what they could think that they
could get away with with telling us to
do
and i'm and i don't understand how
people are okay with this
and totally forget the history of union
organizers being killed
by cartel members which uh a lot of
people point
directly to coca-cola for organizing you
see that
the left used to understand this but
then they got distracted by transgender
pronouns
yes you see this meme where it's a a pig
with a monocle and a top hat
and it says buy our product and there's
an antifa guy and he's yelling and then
below it it says buy our product but
product is big and rainbow
and the person takes the mask i was like
oh i guess that i guess that works
you know it's amazing to me how you have
this tribalism on the left which i
believe is really rooted in
not entirely but mostly rooted in hating
conservatives and thinking they're evil
whereas as the saying goes you know the
left thinks conservatives are evil
the conservatives thinks that the left
is misguided
conservatives care about being left
alone
simple policy it's often the arguments
you'll hear from from right-wing
individuals
not entirely the left they do argue for
things like universal healthcare and
stuff
but at least online it's very much
owning the cons
you do have the right version of that
but what i've noticed is that
where do the seats of power lie on the
left and the right
on the right it is not the q and on
people certainly they're influential in
their own right
and that's kind of you know weird but
the most prominent voices
and the most powerful and largest are
like conservative inc
you know run of the mill mainstream look
at ben shapiro
he is your typical conservative he is
particularly mainstream you know in
terms of
left or right look at the left though
it's ocasio-cortez
12 million followers getting a hundred
thousand concurrent views
not moderate mainstream democrats so the
overton window is shifted to the left
and it's remarkable when i hear the left
say it's shifted right i'm like do you
know anything about the past decade of
politics
trump it's like less war you know what
are you talking about when they said
when
i guess you know what's funny it's
nationalism when you don't want to go
blow up other countries and it's a bad
thing
i guess what about we saw i keep
thinking about the saudi princes like we
talk about the wealthiest elite of the
globe
as the banking system but how do the
princes and the kings of assad
tie into this because they say like
elon's the richest man in the world but
he's not
he's just the richest man on the books
you have the saudi king
and the princes that are like
trillionaires you know they own the
country
and all the people in it um and
the united states sold them a bunch of
weapons like trump yeah but
sold out sold us out to saudi arabia
yeah that's not trump
it's it's it's a weapons deal it's the
us it's the office of the president
it includes trump but it's trump it's
it's it's obama it's bush it's going
to you said all of them when you said he
was like a holdover of occupy wall
street i don't agree i just think he
happened to be rich but he's a sellout
he would have sold us out in a heartbeat
he did no i think trump was a raging
bull that was stampeding through the
ivory tower
and so what the occupy wall street
people were like this is really
interesting because split you had bernie
sanders challenging the machine but then
he joined the machine
and then you had donald trump who was
this wealthy billionaire elite who then
started
ranting and raving about how he didn't
like it and challenging the
establishment it's kind of weird how
that twist occurred
but i think you had a lot of people from
occupy who eventually just threw their
arms in the air and said send in the
bull
like you know what man what's going to
fix this just have him rob about for a
little bit
yeah i mean what happened so here's my
here's my take on trump i mean he was
you know the raging bull he couldn't be
controlled he was genuinely outside this
system
and they couldn't control him but once
he actually got power he just got
kind of completely ruled by the
establishment uh
you know they got all the establishment
republicans got their people in the
administration and nothing really
started happening until the last year of
the administration
you know who i think is one of the most
evil people on the planet is jack dorsey
i really do mean it especially having
talked to him a couple years ago
and we've had some chat back and forth
on twitter and twitter games and stuff
i think his whole schtick
is doing dramatically evil things
and then you know putting up putting a
layer of you know covering it up and
burying it
under some you know lie about wanting to
be better and
and do the right thing and how we're
just it's so hard for us
because he's got this statement he just
put out lydia pulled it up where he
talks about he says i do not celebrate
or feel pride in having to ban
real donald trump from twitter we're
trying so hard to
to build a new system blah blah blah i
don't believe it
i think jack is completely self-centered
he is completely authoritarian he's one
of the
worst possible like like versions of
this idea of i'm smarter than you and i
know it you poor stupid person so you
think he's like a modern
uh robespierre no not necessarily i mean
robespierre was psychotic he wasn't a
first
they called him the uncorruptable so
yeah so you're saying when twitter
tweeted yesterday that they strongly
condemn
internet shutdowns that are quote hugely
harmful
because they violate basic human rights
and the principles of the hashtag open
internet that they weren't genuine and
honest
this is like a psychological abuse where
it's the ver it's the sa
it's it's it's a it is as if he is
punching you repeatedly in the stomach
while saying he's so sorry but it's your
own fault and for your own good
it is psychotic what jack has
consistently done for the past several
years
promising roads to redemption and
decentralization and blockchain
technology we're gonna do all these
great things we're gonna help everybody
he is the spokesperson
for gaslighting duplicitousness and
that's what he's doing right now
twitter nuked 70 000 accounts
and they were not q anon accounts one of
them was carrie smith's account unsafe
spaces
which was just an intellectual dark web
kind of middle-of-the-road
liberal anti-welcome account there was
also uh
some some podcasts that were center left
but anti-woke that got banned and then
jack comes out and says
oh but we're trying so hard no what he's
doing to you is smacking you across the
face
and then he's saying it's for your own
good why do you make me do this to you
and he says it every single time and you
keep going back to him
i i'm so sick of twitter i'm uh i said
it before i was like i'm not gonna use
it i started using it again
but i'm i really do mean it that when i
said i wasn't gonna
use twitter meaningfully any anymore i'm
gonna post whatever i i did it i did
whether i used to post my videos i used
to post articles i used to actively
engage
now i've slowed all that down i'll still
post some articles here and there i
think are important but now i just
basically
i've been trolling it's really what i do
i'll post something like i you know i
tweeted
if history has taught us anything it's
always trust the government to let us
know about the ongoing legislative
legitimacy of all these threats and to
give up their power and i just don't
care anymore
twitter is a trash platform led by
extremely wealthy manipulative
authoritarians who think you are all too
stupid
to run your own government and and he
knows you know what
he can keep doing this but i think
people realize that he's full of it that
tweet about uganda
coming right after this election where
just a couple months ago
twitter blocked one of the most
consequential stories of this election
to protect
joe biden the hunter biden story was
blocked and shut down the new york post
was suspended and then jack was like
well it was a really hard decision heck
materials
shut up i've got active tweets right now
that are very serious
violations of the tw of twitter's rules
that are a threat to me and my family
they will not remove why
and jack knows me because they are evil
people who don't care
they are duplicitous authoritarians i am
sick of twitter man
i'm sick of reading about what jack is
lying to about this time
meanwhile he's making all this money and
he doesn't actually care to help
anybody oh but you know what they do
these ultra wealthy people
use that extraction of resources like
everything that's been happening over
the past year they've extracted all of
our resources
they love it and then what do they do
you get people like mackenzie bezos
dumping all of it into more
manipulative fundamentalist leftist
dogma
and it's only it's going to keep going
now i'll tell you what the solution is
gab's got it gab's got it right
persuasion
it is it is about being resourceful
clever
and doing hard work gab built their own
infrastructure
try and take them down they're going to
keep doing it that's what you got to do
the other thing i think is when we talk
about politics being you know downstream
from culture and you
you said how do you solve that it's easy
go further upstream
if someone is is taking a dump in your
water supply and you're like going to
get a bucket of water from the river and
there's like poop floating in it
you got to go further upstream to get
your water yeah max keiser says whoever
has the bitcoin makes the laws
it was clever in relation to who has the
money makes the laws but
in the future it's going to be the
crypto yeah uh
there's there's talk about government
regulated like government coins like
cryptocurrency made by governments
so usdc well china just announced that
they're working on a global currency to
release for everyone
out there so again as we said
cryptocurrency could be something great
could be something that could be used to
enslave a lot of people to track trace
and database people in a very easy
system
now when you look at twitter's
announcement especially with the q anon
people
they made sure to specifically say not
just q and on people but q anon
associated
content very vague very generalized
language
no accountability no transparency no
court of law
no reason given to individuals hey why
were you banned
none of that and at least if you're
gonna do it at least
justify it at least give some recourse
give some reason give some explanation
but these people are so emboldened
that they're like we don't even have to
tell you why we're destroying your
livelihood we're destroying your
communications
we're destroying your way of life being
able to actually get your ideas out
there to the political discourse
we don't have churches anymore we don't
have bars we don't have any way to
communicate and talk to our fellow man
except for twitter they are the monopoly
they are the highway they control it
they have a toll booth and they are a
family-friendly show i i
have other language i want to use here
but i'm going to i'm just going to stop
writing
polish no i don't think could i curse in
polish i don't think so
i think i think you can actually be a
bit more disparaging and polish because
they
they'd have to be like can we get
someone who knows polishing they're
gonna have to translate a whole bunch of
uh i can't even say it but don't go over
the top but say something
say criticize them in polish
[Music]
[Laughter]
the only one one of the only that one of
the few words i know in polish i think
you said
yes right it's hard to control it's like
it's like in uh uh
what what what show was it where that
whenever lady get mad she started
speaking spanish
she yelled at her husband you remember
that i don't remember what it is
whatever
also how they do these mass bannings is
quite insidious extremely insidious
because it's
it shows you how you can't separate the
privacy issue from the censorship issue
it's because they know so much about us
that they can pinpoint exactly who all
the trump supporters are
on the platform but also think about
this they can also pinpoint who the
undecided voters are
so imagine how they're using that
information in addition to using the
former to ban people
i'll tell you something funny um there
was you know donald trump posted to
youtube
and they immediately took it down and
then suspect gave him a strike and
suspended him
so i saw people posting about what trump
had posted
and they were saying someone posted like
i saw the video it was crazy
it was trump saying like god calls on
you to to come and save this country in
the 20th
and i was like what did donald trump
post a video that's crazy
so i looked for it couldn't find it i
eventually found a video claiming to be
the original video and that's what it
said it said this is the video
and it was like on the 20th you know god
has given you a calling and it was like
crazy stuff
so i posted it in a group chat with some
other reporters and personalities asking
if anybody knew what the video was some
people are saying this is it
and do you know what these other people
saw it just said this video this link
has been removed due to being suspicious
so they couldn't actually some people
could see it some people couldn't and
then it turns out the the rumor is right
now
trump posted a snippet from his speech
his statements he made it at the
at the border wall so i don't know
exactly what that video was
but even in private messages they're
banning things i'll tell you one thing
really funny
i often send myself things on on
facebook
i'll use it as like a notepad so if like
if someone sends me a story and i need
to
keep track of it or if i'm looking at
something to buy i'll like just send it
to myself
and i recently was looking at i sent
myself a link to like buy i don't know
it's like a panini press or something
and then i went in my messages and i was
looking for the link and then i noticed
it said this has been removed or
whatever
i sent it to myself facebook went into
my message to myself as
a reminder and removed what i was trying
to remind myself of and i don't even
know what it was
it was probably a link to bit shoot or
something it's kind of like we're in
the matrix in the movie we're on the
ship and we're talking to people in the
matrix and they're like i'm being
censored this matrix is censoring me
and you can't be like go use this other
matrix program in the matrix because
it's all in the matrix you have to leave
the matrix
the proprietary software with these
algorithms these proprietary algorithms
are tracking you
and they're they're they're moving you
around dude you know what's so annoying
we turned on we turned on the tv a
couple nights ago and there was a
commercial it's my tv yeah and all we
ever watch is like family guy and we got
a puppy chow commercial yeah
yeah hold on i have not posted about the
dog
i have not i've not posted anything
about dogs
luke got a dog yeah i i'm exploiting it
to the fullest extent on my instagram
on luke we are changing but but why is
it that my account on my tv
when i opened it up a commercial plate
because the tv heard the dog
and i was watching that yeah but so
they say that they're not actually
spying on audio and then it's artificial
intelligence that knows
is it possible that the ai is so smart
it knew that yeah it's tracking luke it
knows that luke has a dog
probably that's right a new puppy also
if you that's what no
you know what you're you're completely
right it probably saw that luke and i
are friends on facebook
that we've actually been in the same
place the same time you're on a show
together and luke went to a dog place
and yep it's not so much about knowing
on a show it's about
the gps being identical and about us
being friends and about luke posting
about dogs
well we went to that puppy store that
had that
there it is that dog that they were
considering getting and we never did
we went to a a uh puppy store
and my phone probably logged the uh near
you
location and then they put a commercial
up for it there's a beautiful dog there
that
we almost got by the way but we didn't
but there was also a yeah
there was messages that i tried to send
you regarding defensive
measures and defensive stuff that i
couldn't send to you i remember trying
to send you like hey we should probably
get this
and then the link never went through
which just shows you that it's not just
it's not just censorship it's also
knowing everything about you
that that should terrify someone because
these companies are getting more and
more powerful because
data is becoming the new oil and when we
look at a lot of industries they're
absolutely dominated with knowing who
a customer is what they're doing and
with that power
they could do a lot of incredible things
and i i remember this even before
donald trump was on the political scene
that there was mainline
data scientific studies talking about
how facebook and google
could rig elections this was even before
trump
they were talking about how they could
just manipulate the algorithm manipulate
manipulate the search results and they
could have an effect
on elections that could sway it in
either direction that they chose
it to go to the ceo of reddit said it
yeah he gave an interview and he's like
oh yeah we could totally swing an
election he's like
we couldn't get away for it for too long
but we could totally do it and there was
discussion
they probably did i bet reddit tried to
do that google suddenly did it yeah but
for a little bit there was a discussion
saying hey this is too much power we
should regulate this we should stop it
we should intervene we should break up
the monopolies
but that conversation lasted for about
five minutes and then it ended and no
one else
even talked about it after those data
studies came out because they block it
yes they're like oh no people are going
to break us up quick change
dangle keys in front of them on facebook
police very comfortable
they feed you nice steak that you think
tastes good
they want you they want to keep you
inside and get make you rich
so you can exit them about rich you can
exit the matrix or you can ban the
matrix so can we talk for a moment about
how twitter somehow managed to make the
dictatorial government of uganda
look like the sympathetic party yeah
right
yeah that's a good point that you bring
up here because the the tweet that i
referenced
was specifically towards an open
internet but just for uganda
not for anyone else yeah i mean the
argument i think the ugandan government
is using
which again these are brutal dictators
but the argument they're using is
well we don't want these companies
coming and interfering in our election
banning our government ministers from
their accounts and
uh again brutal dictatorship but are
they wrong though because
tech companies are i think this is
pretty well known now
they are arms off u.s influence abroad
think about
oh i'll go back about facebook in fact
one of the uh probably for my favorite
quote from the book is
from a government insider who told me
that before trump
the uh the state department and the
foreign policy elites
saw these tech platforms or social media
freedom as a means of achieving regime
change abroad by allowing dissidents to
speak
by allowing uh information to get out
around the
authority the the government approved
channels but as soon as trump comes
along
and brexit comes along and populism
comes along suddenly they start to worry
well uh oh our regime might get changed
it's not that what we've learned from
the statement on uganda
was that they like the idea of using
social media to control elections
that's it it's it's not it's not
inconsistent
they don't want twitter to be banned
because they want to manipulate the
ugandan elections
and they want they want twitter to be
the monopoly in the united states
so they can manipulate elections it's
the same thing and
the timeline here matters because
correct me if i'm wrong
it was first ugandan government
officials that were banned by twitter
and facebook
then they decided to shut down facebook
and twitter
and now facebook and twitter are working
with the state department to bring back
social media
into uganda and then we also have to
understand there's a lot of also
fingerprints with the state department
working with social media when it comes
to the arab spring
when it comes to ukraine and other very
important
geopolitical battles that were happening
that
i would argue the the tech oligarchs and
state department were working for the
favor
of the us in many of those key instances
that
do deserve to be looked at right now so
the way the state department influence
works uh
is you know they have the all these ngos
that they send to countries
and these ngos are how they do political
organization
uh they also you know fund media outlets
and so on and social media allowed them
to supercharge those efforts
inside whichever country they were
targeting that's why they like it that's
what got me uh booted from venezuela
some occupy activists on twitter started
tweeting at a bunch of venezuelan
personalities
that i worked for usaid and was in
venezuela to subvert and overthrow the
revolution that's what they said
to overthrow the revolution and i'm
literally just some dude who went from
vice
and i i chose to like no one advice told
me to do it i said hey i want to go to
venezuela and they're like alright go
for it that's an interesting um
perspective that if you ban the matrix
it doesn't necessarily mean you're
righteous
like evil there's can still be chaos and
destruction
in the real world in in the matrix world
where on the ships you know there can be
pirates and and dictators and things
like this ugandan dictator apparently i
don't know much about
him um so the matrix is an evil
it's just a powerful tool yeah that
happens to be under the control of
america which is why
ugandan dictators don't like it and we
say america
but i mean what is america at this point
corporate
uh corporate banking billionaire elites
yeah that have like hijacked the us
military it's really not
america they just have control of our
military i really do think that
uh it's almost like they want to make
sure there's a permanent underclass
that there's no upward mobility like
creating a new royalty
they're the elites they're the ones who
get to walk freely in congress and and
through the capital
they're the ones who get special
exemptions from the rules and the law
and things like this
and so everything they're doing with
destroying the economy
it results in certain jobs become like
you make
certain individuals making more and more
money and it results in the regular
working-class people being completely
destroyed by it
and when the wealth of say your your
average you know middle american
is destroyed their chances of moving up
and improving their lives becomes
zero basically but the elites who
control assets don't lose that so so
think about this way
if you're rich and you're worried about
the economic collapse
it's real easy you put your money into
something you take
you take a bunch of your liquid you know
assets assets you buy hard assets you
buy property you buy resources you buy
the means of production
then the working-class people who have a
small savings need to buy food
they can't afford to put their money
into something safe
so they lose their wealth they lose
their ex they lose control so it's
almost like the bottom's being pulled
out
but the rich people have a bar to hang
on to and the people down below don't
nope they fall down well they've been
doing this they've been they've been
stealing from a lot of people through
the process of inflation and deflation
when the market is high they sell when
the market is low
they uh obviously buy up a bunch of
goods and we have to understand a lot of
these people a lot of these kind of
whether it's the federal reserve a lot
of the bigger banks they know
what's going to happen ahead of time
because they're the ones setting this
policy
and they could decide i'm going to sell
it all i'm going to buy it all and
they've been doing this kind of system
ever since we got rid of the gold
standard but what you need to understand
is it's not a conspiracy
as though like a bunch of bankers get
together and go yeah we're gonna tank
the market no what happens is
they'll put out their statement saying
here's when we think this will happen
here's what we're going to buy
and then all of the big banks make a
massive move which will drop the values
of certain things
and then when people panic sell because
people just do they buy it up
case in point bitcoin recently yeah fell
down to 30.
and it was funny it was at like 31 and a
bunch of people i saw uh
you know were tweeting at me saying
things like i'm gonna sell now and then
buy back when it's at the bottom
and then within a few hours it went
right back up to 35 and i was like well
if you sold you screwed yourself
yeah the the market cap went from 1
trillion to 840 billion
it lost 160 billion dollars don't quote
me on the exact numbers so
i think there was a coordinated sell-off
of 100 billion dollars but a bunch of
people made but it wasn't coordinated in
the sense that like a bunch of guys got
together it could
what you say definitely happens it may
have also been coordinated i don't know
it
seemed very what happens is you have a
you have an avalanche you have all of
this
it's piling up and then there are people
ready to buy at certain numbers
one person happens to hold a large
amount of coins because he's a miner
perhaps so it's a company
they put it all up for sale at at a
certain price to make all that money
and then it causes everything to just
cast machines that are watching and
they'll
trigger cells and then what happens is
it's human psychology
regular people who have invested what
little they had panic
and then they sell it all and that's how
the wealth gets transferred to the
wealthy because people panic
it's like this is why i don't i love
going to casinos we recently went to a
casino and i i got
man it was amazing i put like 20 bucks
down on high card flush and won like 800
bucks and i started tipping like crazy
it was amazing
i don't like playing poker though you
know why because i i you know i used to
i just have a lot of fun playing poker
to play magic the gathering so if you're
good at like
reading people then you'd be great at
poker but you're taking money from poor
people who don't know what they're doing
the same way dude
yeah it's like that you make money off
the people not the house i like playing
against the house i lose i go to casinos
for fun i don't go there to make money
but i don't like the idea of ripping off
the working-class people who don't know
what they're doing so i'm always
advising people
you need to know what you're doing you
need to get sound advice don't get it
from me but just
you know panic is where they rip you off
yeah and don't listen to the mainstream
media that was telling you that
bitcoin's dead it's over
it's never coming back and i've been
seeing those articles for
years now and i've been kind of you know
combating it in my own way but as we
said
on the show a couple days ago again not
financial advice but
it's usually not the best thing to buy
high and to sell low
that's what usually the average person
does it's it's not
a good strategy but when you look at the
mainstream media and they're talking
points that's what they tell you to do
i go to four chance biz board for my
financial advice
when you see lots of the pink whoa jacks
where they're all freaking out saying
the stocks are going down
that's when you buy stunks you know i
love this one article said
bitcoin investors could lose everything
i
can't believe it's like it's so obvious
what that was
they were trying to scare new investors
into selling everything
and it worked and then the price dropped
they
they bought high and then the price
tanked while they panicked and then the
people with access and means
bought all of it back up and now it's
going right back up to 40k
i say it happens all the time so i'm not
going to tell you what you should do or
give you advice i'll tell you what i'll
do
when i buy bitcoin i just sit on it
you're supposed to hold hold on for dear
life
but anyway i digress you know we got
into the bitcoin conversation again just
because it's been so prevalent the
reality is
consistently those with lots of money
can sit on it and protect it and use it
to grow their their resources and
control and power
and everything we're seeing with the
lockdowns and everything we're seeing
with
you know these these uh these bailouts
all it does is strip what little the
working class have
and you know the problem is many of
these people are cheering for it
clapping thunderous applause
the wealthy are like we want to steal
all your money and they go
yay and then they do
when you say like go upstream from
from uh money if if you really want to
solve from culture
well you want to go upstream from
culture and i was like well
the rich people are what are controlling
culture upstream from that it led me to
crypto but what's
what's above that is is it steel mills
no it's producing iron mines and weapons
it's producing culture but what does
that mean so if there are if there are
if there's a stream of cultural issues
that ends with a political policy
and someone is throwing garbage in the
river then produce culture
above them it's like the strongest
gorilla would
is the one who dictates the culture of
the of the tribe
i mean kind of i guess i'm just saying
that's how it worked back in the day
people
need to be persuasive and resourceful
you need to have access
and means and confidence and you do that
by inspiring and
building culture by teaching people to
do things that are fun
but i'll tell you what really drives one
of one of the things that really drives
people
is being cheered on by others it feels
good when you have a crowd of people
like clapping for you people love it
it's why skateboarding is is so great
you go to a skate park
and you don't got to be the best
skateboarder in the world but if people
see you
maybe you've only been skateboarding for
a few months you finally learned how to
kickflip and you're really bad at it
kickflip is like a basic trick for those
i don't know
you could be at a park it's clear that
you're not that good and you're trying
as hard as you can to land this kickflip
when you finally do everyone will cheer
and clap for you it's not about you
being the best it's about you
overcoming yourself and doing better
every day but then if you are really
really good you go there you know
when you skate and you do well people
cheer and clap for it's a very positive
environment
some kids can be nasty that's what we
need we need people who oppose the
wokeness
and the creepy you know cancel culture
stuff to mock it
and make it desirable for people to mock
it to belittle it
to have a good time this is why comedy
is so powerful
so we need more comedians like ryan long
for instance who routinely rocks not
mocks not just the left but also the
right on occasion
making it fun to say the extremism is
stupid
to make it a point that you will be
cheered for and celebrated and
successful
if you tell the crazy people to stop or
you you point out their absurdities
and like being an artist in general i
think
is a great way to control the culture
but then
the money the rich people are gonna come
to you once you succeed and they're
gonna try and buy you out
and it works well not always but it's
it's very tempting
i don't know what you do with all that
money some of these people get some of
these these
these big brands and the sponsorships
they've done
i don't want to name anybody but there's
like you know youtubers who have
endorsed political candidates
who like who are not political that's
like look i do news commentary in
politics so for me saying who i'm gonna
vote for i think is is on me
but there are like non-political
youtubers who are like i'm gonna vote
for hillary clinton or whatever and it's
like
now why are you doing that there's no
incentive for you to turn off minecraft
and start talking about hillary clinton
that makes no sense
that to me sounds like it was a paid
endorsement or something and that's when
you start getting into dangerous
territory
but you know it is what it is people are
going to take sponsorships for whatever
i'm not going to think twice about
it well it's also it's also quite
profitable you want to win the
if you're not that political maybe you
just want to win the failure of the
elites at youtube
or at these entertainment companies
because you know the way to do that is
the virtue signal
yep yeah i'm you know i
i know that you know it's deep seated in
uh youtube and google this leftist and
this woke stuff
but i do think that there are i think
most people don't like it
i really really believe that's true the
problem is i think they're all just
terrified in their cowards
and and i'm sorry i'm not trying to be
mean but there's
there's somebody who's willing to say
i'll say what i want when i want
and it tends to be trump's boys are all
getting banned because they'll just say
what they want they don't care and
they're the people on the left
traditional liberals
they tell me behind the scenes all the
time i have business calls with people
who work for companies peripheral to
google or within google and they're like
we love your stuff man
we completely agree about this you know
we're fans of like george carlin and
chappelle but
oh man i don't know i lose my job and
i'm like yeah you're a coward bro
i think you're right that it stems from
fear like um
whether they're afraid because they
don't understand
big the way that technology works so the
the unknown creates like a fear
of the unknown so they just go along
with it or
they're afraid or they're more
viscerally afraid of actually being
banned themselves but i think the fear
of not understanding
how politics works how laws are written
how we should teach
kids how to write laws i think they care
about that though i think i think the
concern is
are the people going to be mean to me
it's just very disempowering to not know
to not understand how the how the power
structure works i think they just don't
want to be fired
they don't want to be mobbed by the
social justice warriors well they know
that if
they get fired for being anti-woke
they're not gonna get a job ever again
indeed so what grow up the biggest
polling error
and i agree with that that they should
grow up i mean you know uh people
endured a lot
worse go work for veritas whistle on
this stuff for uh for political
activities
but the biggest polling error by far in
the 2020 election
was the white middle class not the white
working class
uh they actually predicted the white
working class vote pretty well the
pollsters
but they missed the the white
middle-class vote
by i think it was about uh
over 20-point polling error really yes
it was it was massive it was the biggest
expect and what was the reality they
were expecting to be split pretty evenly
between uh
uh biden and trump in fact it was like
over 20 points in favor of trump from uh
white middle-class uh voters
um uh what was the middle no i think it
was actually employment
so i don't quote me that was it was
employment are they in white collar jobs
rather than blue collars oh okay okay
right now
and uh that makes perfect sense to me
because the people in white collar jobs
are most afraid of the weakness
yeah because they'll it's not it's not
just that uh
they will take your job from you it's
that they will salt the earth to make
sure you could never have a job again
and that's what people are afraid of and
uh
really you know what man whatever look i
guess
when you're you're accustomed to a
certain comforts
it's really easy to scare people into
losing all of it
you know so they grow up and they have
this middle class life and they get a
white-collar job and they got their 401k
and they get married they have kids and
they're like heaven forbid i have to
actually live like humans lived a
hundred years ago
it's scary i get it you don't know how
to survive on your own anymore you don't
know how to grow your own food or hunt
or anything like that
and it's not necessarily something we
should be doing we have this you know
wonderful technology and access
but the worst case scenario for getting
fired from a job for standing up for
this is not going to hunt
and becoming a wild man with your wild
family it's literally just getting a
crummier job or something
or i don't know going and working for a
company that will let you work for them
but too many people are just scared and
i think it's
it's it's kind of sad it's cowardly and
um you know what what is this saying all
that is required for evil to win is for
good men to do nothing
good people to do nothing and there's
the other quote uh what is it
uh let it never be said that a small
group of determined people can't change
the world indeed it's the only thing
that's ever have that that
ever has so how many people are just
sitting on their hands saying it won't
be me
because i'm too scared and what happened
to the people who are like i'm gonna get
on a boat for three months with limited
resources and crash
onto the shores of an empty country just
figure it out
think about the people who are on that
boat coming from europe going to
north america or going anywhere else you
had no idea what you were going to see
when you got there
in fact the first group that landed you
know in new england
is just rocks and trees and they're like
get to work
one glimmer of optimism i saw last year
is something that could potentially give
more people courage because what
what makes people less cowardly what
gives them courage i think it's when
they see
people that the media tries to cancel
but
uh it completely fails to do so and
there were so many examples of this last
year actually they tried to cancel
michelle mulken both conservatives and
liberals tried to cancel her
they failed she actually got her show on
newsmax off like a few weeks after that
so
utterly failed she got more
opportunities they tried to cancel jack
pasobic
they tried to cancel peter thiel uh
darren beatty they tried to cancel him
he actually got a new white house
appointment
and the me and the white house
essentially told the uh the media to uh
to
f off when they uh you know sort of
start
outrage cycle over that so the more
examples you have like that
of people the media tries to cancel and
just completely fails at it i think the
more courage you'll see from ordinary
people
i think trump is another example why
people are supporting him so hard right
now is because they're trying to cancel
him from social media and now they're
trying to
impeach him and cancel them from
politics so people are like
no resist if you can do it i can do it
well
this is i want to kind of talk to your
point because what you were saying about
people kind of paying the mortgages
and trying to make ends meet a lot of
these people are controlled that way
they're controlled in other ways but
a few years ago i got drunk and hammered
with the white house press corps
the conversation was off the record a
lot of them are alcoholics i won't be
naming names or saying what they
they uh who they who they are
specifically well you just said all of
them uh
well majority of the white house press
white house press corps a couple years
ago
i'm not going to be specific here the
conversation was off the record pause
real quick
journalists are notoriously alcoholics
no joke yeah when i worked for vice
there was like a jaeger machine on the
counter and people had liquor bottles
all over the place
a huge substance abuse problem amongst
journalists
also depression rates but that's a whole
other story to get into
and after getting hammered with with
them we were talking i won't name the
specific person
they were like hey man look i have a
family i have a daughter
i have to pay off my bills i just got to
do what i'm told and that's exactly what
i'm doing
so that was the major sentiment from a
lot of them that were breaking down
and telling me how they have no kind of
free will to even express ideas that
they want to express or investigate
stories that they want to investigate
and they're like you know i like your
work i
i i love you but i can't even tell
anyone because i'm afraid
of uh this kind of chilling effect going
on of even mentioning you
and they all just that's why they're
depressed alcoholics
they must be very demolarizing being
essentially the inquisitors of the elite
yeah
all they have to do is i'll stand up and
say no i'm not interested but they
but they they value money and uh
wealth and access over integrity honor
to honor and loyalty
so just to be clear i'm not feeling
sorry for mainstream journalists
no no no no uh i have i have contempt
and disdain for these people because
when given the choice between
standing tall and saying you know i
refuse
they say just write the check i'll say
whatever you want
give me the money and i'll do whatever
you want me to do it's it's really funny
there are you know certain youtube
personalities
and certain left-wing personalities who
absolutely did this
when it came to uh weave you're familiar
with weave
oh the hat the uh the hacker with the uh
notorious tattoo yes the notorious
tattoo from you know world war ii
germany
so you know what 2012 2013 there were
many left-wing activists who were
praising him and to a certain degree i
don't act like they were saying he was a
good person
outright but they were defending him
they were hanging out with him they were
laughing with him they're taking photos
with him they're on couches smiling and
hugging and all that stuff
and then when we got into deep into the
culture war with the fascists in the far
right
these people immediately were like i i
never know
i uh i hate him i i'm like
you guys were like shoulder and shoulder
singing songs together like don't play
that game
no you're cowards and then there was uh
quinn norton who's a journalist when she
got hired by the new york times
and then the left tried canceling her
saying she's friends with weave
she said fu weaves my friend and i was
like wow
now that's a spying that is integrity
and then she ended up resigning because
of it
because the the new because new york
times is cowardly and they're pathetic
so you know look you could you get it
you could make a choice
do you have values are you a person of
good moral standing or are you a
spineless wet noodle
who will just fold the sign of of any
threat or any risk
talk about weakness man well i have
values like
jesus i want to go in there to the
temple and flip the tables over and
scream at the merchants for ripping us
off and creating this usury but
i don't because i will be executed no
that's different
these people are in a position where
they can't flip out like luke was saying
no one's telling them to flip out no and
destroy things so they can't express
themselves genuinely they can't ask
questions they can't uh you know go
through the normal
thinking process they have to literally
read a script in many instances
they can't say there are two genders i
would rather die on my feet than live on
my knees well that's why a lot of these
people have huge substance abuse
problems and
uh you know for a lot of them i just
feel sorry for them to be honest with
you to an extent i do
but i also think if you
are going to be a wet noodle and just
give up because someone's being mean to
you
well then why should i defend you you
don't have to defend but the empathy is
key
having the empathy doesn't mean that you
feel bad for them or that you agree with
them it just means that you understand
what they're going of course i just
explained it i understand exactly what
they're going through
and i think their only way out is to
stand up and say no
but they won't do it there's more than
just that i would imagine
uh i disagree well this is why they're
so afraid of social media because on
social media you can create these kind
of preference cascades very easily
a preference cascade you know it's when
people have all these preferences that
they're hiding because they're afraid of
other people judging them and calling
them out and
leaving comments breaking down their
illusion and the bull crap that they get
paid by special interest
to push now if you remember this in the
early kind of onsens of the internet
every website had a comment section oh
yeah yeah
this is when i first realized that there
was a movement building against free
speech
journalists respond in the comment
sections and i was like the comment
section is amazing because every bull
crap article that was pushing an agenda
was
automatically called out upvoted people
are saying this is bull crap because of
this level
look at this evidence go to this website
and then what happened they started
slowly and surely getting rid of the
comment sections
everywhere on all the main line
mainstream media publications it
and now it's curated one of the debut
articles on breitbart tech when we
launched in 2015 one of the first
articles we published on that vertical
the war on comment sections
that was one of the first signs that was
coming and then remember gab launched it
was a dissenter
yeah universal comments for all articles
and they went after
gab like crazy because that was it when
you can read the comments you were like
really
so they had to get rid of it instantly
banned from every browser extension
what is great technology and then they
then okay and then this is why gab is
quite important then they kind of
built their own browser they they use
open source chrome code
right and then made the gab browser yeah
building their own servers like their
own social network their own servers
their own browser their own comment
section their own phone
they're very very resourceful i think
i'm gonna get on gab
yeah yeah well donald trump's there i
don't he's not really posting or
anything like that
well let's uh let's let's jump over to
super chats if you have not already
smash that like button subscribe hit the
notification bell we are live monday the
friday 8 p.m
and now we go to the portion of the show
where we take your comments and read
what you say
as many as we can because we do get a
ton of super chats
so let's just jump in tom bowersock says
this is my last super chat before i
joined the private site
dropping youtube membership well thank
you tom and if you
feel like tom as well go to timcast.com
and become a member
we are it's still very beta-e there's
some issues some people are having
trouble logging in but
you know just remain calm and we're
working through it i appreciate your
support
but by becoming a member not only do you
get access to exclusive members only
comment
content which we'll be putting up very
soon start producing we're also going to
be doing live events
at our studio venue for very limited
very limited audiences i'm talking like
less than 10 people maybe around then
and only members will get access to
the tickets which are first come first
serve so again go to timcast.com sign up
but more importantly
considering all the censorship
considering the things we're talking
about literally one of the experts of
tech censorship you know alum is here
with uh
your book is deleted big tax battle to
erase the trump movement and steal the
election
both of which came true literally wrote
the book on censorship
seriously please if you want to support
the show go to timcast.com become a
member because
the real key to security and success
that we have seen with many podcasts is
a strong
and loyal user base that contributes
because then you
are insulated against the the threats of
censorship the threats
it really comes down to this if they've
already done this to like elijah shaffer
gone after his advertisers numerous
times he knows what the blaze
that's why it's so crucial that we build
up a large network of you know core
users who are members
because then you're almost invincible
you're you're insulated you're protected
that's why timcast.com is available
let's read some more
karma and kerosene says tim we're trying
to influence culture like you talked
about
my band karma and kerosene just released
our first full album
we write rock for libertarians and
conservatives come check us out on
youtube
well there you go guys check out karma
and kerosene that's culture
i want to tell you guys a secret it's
actually not a secret i talked about it
before youtube invited me to a special
meeting on
how to i forgot what it was called but
it was something about
de-radicalization and you know social
justice
and their concern was that there was a
lot of there were a lot of people being
radicalized by jihadi content on youtube
and they were trying to figure out how
to make it so that people who would go
on youtube
would not view the more extreme you know
islamic culture as them they would view
more mainstream
regular american and western culture and
so they had a bunch of really
bad ideas one of the ideas was to make
videos
telling people they were wrong and they
were dumb and they were doing the wrong
thing
and i was just like that's a terrible
idea because think about you got these
young kids
they're in the uk they're in the u.s and
there are these videos targeting them on
youtube that are free speech that was
the problem youtube was like we can't
just take down these videos
that are advocating for fundamentalist
islam so what do we do and i was just
like
just make normal content that's it have
have people explain themselves as
regular people don't make it some
big thing they don't get it though they
still hold this view where they're like
we need to tell people they're dumb and
bash them over the head with it it's all
about just
making regular stuff for regular people
and it's like when you see chris pratt
and he's wearing the gadsden flag shirt
and they freaked out because of it but
everybody loves chris pratt
that's what it's all about just be a
regular person do regular stuff well
it's good to have some inside
information about what they're doing
about extremism because now the
americans are going to be the extremists
yeah it's good to know
jonathan galterini says check the
executive order trump signed and the
letter he sent to pence and pelosi today
the letter is actually dated tomorrow
but it's interesting it's easier to find
if you check the rsbn twitter page also
trump's hearing is set for the 19th
is it the 19th i heard that the trial
wasn't going to be until till after
look man i i've been waking up every day
since the election with someone saying
today's the day it's going to happen the
states are going to flip that's going to
happen it's like every day someone's
saying it never happens
you know it just people just want to
believe i guess
dylan keller says you need a name for
your website members may i suggest
beanie bros or beanie brigade
also you should sell a beanie that has a
picture of a beanie on us
thank you and spin the male vitality
please oh we don't have that anymore i
do
oh no no no no no you have dr jones is
primal doctor jones probably you
spin the yes yeah i will spin that
spin the primal youth we got to stop
inadvertently advertising
for this man do we though do we really
gotta stop well it's kind of funny
is it in frame like it's kind of funny
that alex jones has these health
products and on it says doctor john so
he is dr jones
i i hope not because the man is not a
doctor no i'm spinning it for you alex
whether you're dr jones or not
is he more more or less of a doctor than
jill biden
oh yeah i don't know oh that's an
interesting question good question
yeah spin that primal use well
rogue waya says not my first but
hopefully you'll read this one
tim do you think our overlords would
allow us a session they want us all to
be their slaves
where uh where's the tim that said i'd
rather die in my feet than live on my
knees
i think i just said that yeah you did um
well that's why i'm out you know in the
middle of nowhere
setting up uh a you know big acreage
property for fun
and just being away from the cities and
all that stuff but what you got to
understand
is winning this cultural war in the
conflict in our political system
requires strategy persuasion
and resourcefulness what we thought the
capital was none of that it was the
opposite it scared people it made people
angry
it caused damage to to uh american
relics and to our our nation's capital
it didn't do anything it just hurt trump
the key to winning is like with the
daily wire
with that new movie which you know you
probably heard about right yeah it's
building culture
and getting people interested imagine if
in like 15
years you have some kid who's like i
really want to work for daily wire
studios man they do amazing thrillers
and then they're like that's ben
shapiro's company yeah yeah
yeah it is you want kids to proudly say
that's what i want to be when i grow up
so you've got to make things to inspire
them and participate in the culture
not just you know push barricades down
and there's that cliche story about that
hitler was an artist
and maybe there's something to it but if
he had been
supported if people had like been like
you can do it you can become an artist
maybe he wouldn't have become a crazy
dictator maybe that there's a reason
they all freaked out her
game again yeah right because there was
a push back in
the cultural space and so they were
doing everything they can to seize
the means of cultural production yeah i
know you've got to get to your next
question but did you guys see the vox
article
uh with uh with if we paid attention to
gamergate the capitol hill right
wouldn't have happened
literally that was the headline yeah and
they put out a tweet where they said
there's a straight line from gamergate
to the capitol hill riots yeah
that was the one that was there i don't
think so like as if this 53 year old guy
with a beard
who's like knocking the barricades over
had anything to do with complaining
about the
the character design in you know
battlefield one so the gamergate thing
is that
can you explain it really quick uh no no
you cannot explain it ten words or less
this will be the next book that'll be
the next book
what happened so it was like female
developers
it was like gamers didn't like political
correctness in video games
and they all came to a head over and
then they started fighting the
journalists who did want political
correct and video games and that went on
for a year
hold one of the core elements that led
to that moment was
video game companies would advertise on
games journalism websites
so like you'd go to we'll just call it
game website and say oh you know i'll
pay you a thousand dollars to promote my
game
the website would then write articles
that were supposed to review the game
but it would all be positive coverage
why
they didn't want to lose their paycheck
so it was corrupt
they were writing favorable stories
about their sponsors and getting paid to
do it
so this led to a controversy over ethics
and gaming journalism
there was this specific moment with the
people i'm not going to name which
triggered this and then ultimately it
became very much about
these journalists were social justice
activists
and it's very very simple actually when
you are in the modern digital era
and you have a job that pays you a
salary you need to write articles every
single day in fact
many of these companies because i worked
for advice and i worked fusion the
editors in the morning meeting says what
stories do you have today and they would
say
video game came out yesterday i wrote
about it we we're doing the walk through
guide for you know zelda
but what else can we really write about
oh i know why don't you complain that
zelda
is uh i don't know white so they just
started creating drama they
yes they needed something to write about
so they would have content every day
and they're saying this creation of
drama is what led to
where we're at now there's a lot of
issues around gamergate but the general
idea is
from my perspective having worked for
these companies they were so desperate
to make some kind of daily content
that they just made political issues out
of games
the argument is that that was the first
cultural pushback against
the left therefore it was the first step
on the road to donald trump
i mean you could i i love this narrative
by the way it's there's no truth to it
whatsoever but i love that it's out
there i do think that the rage bait
culture
has kind of led us to become where we're
at now i mean
you could say that liberal media
organization look at what age debates
against
trump what did aoc just say an interview
she said i was scared that the white
supremacists members of congress would
reveal my location should be killed
white supremacists what which guy that
one guy from iowa who lost
it's ridiculous yeah and because they're
they're they're demanding the arrest of
lauren bobert
these people look they're criticizing
the republicans who are calling for
unity
the republicans criticized the left who
called for uni after trump won
it's a never ending i remember like 2018
they were like it's okay to punch a nazi
i think i said it once
in joking and then regretted it and then
other people started saying it and then
it started spiraling out of
now oh there's so it's all over the
place
the problem is it's allegory it's it's
hyperbole there are no nazis these days
nazis was a party of hitler's
you could have a national socialist like
bernie sanders or
donald donald trump any president
he's a national socialist but he's not a
nazi the nazis were hitler's party
right so much of politics these days is
larping like it is with the internet
communists as well people with the
hammer and sickle
in their avatar really they just want
medicare for all yeah
do they really even know what that means
which is a very left-wing policy but
it's
it's just i don't think they know what
it actually means because you know when
i hear people say
universal healthcare medicare for all
i'm like it sounds like you didn't
actually look into it
because you can talk about what bernie
says when he says like uh every other
country on the planet has this why can't
we have it and then he goes ban private
health insurance and you're like well
not no other country does that like most
other countries that have a universal
level of care have private health care
supplemental
so that's why i actually i actually am
in favor of that because i've actually
read into it i've looked at the costs
and i think there's some difficult
challenges
but when i hear these people say you
know and then some people i respect too
jimmy dore's in favor of medicare for
all with no private with banning private
insurance i disagree i think he's wrong
i don't think he's right into it enough
but i respect the guy a whole lot he's
very principled i think many of these
people who say that they're larping
and they don't know what they're saying
they don't know what it means they
didn't look into the costs
ask them oh so what do you do to the 2
million people who lose their job was it
2 million
some massive number of people who will
lose their jobs and then create
massive uh economic crash when a large
portion of our economy is gutted
that's one of the biggest problems we
have we don't have world war
ii to create a national crisis of mass
death that forces us to create national
health services
anyway let's read some more super chats
rob lowe robs lowe's
i have to do it now how many ro all
right
how many lows could rob lowe rob if rob
lowe could rob lowe's
he says tim i was wondering if you would
be okay with having my sister on your
show
she's starting a life coach podcast i
only ask because it could be nice to
have someone
that believes a positive lifestyle and
removing the screen and
clutter of life i won't lie to you uh
probably not
but that's because we we usually don't
book based on you know people messaging
us and stuff
but we will look into it so feel free to
send us an email to was it spin the ufo
or gmail
spin the ufo at gmail.com good morning
sunday morning says what the dems big
tech and nyc is doing with
trump sounds like what the romans called
damn uh damnatio is that what it is
yes damnadio mri after a disliked
politician died his name would be
removed from building statues changed
etc
that's weird and just weird and creepy
let's see jay of legend says doesn't the
10th amendment already protect the bill
of rights from fed state and
the people aka civilians and since the
10 defines people separate of government
it also clarifies the second which would
mean twitter fb et cetera are already
breaking the law
i'm not a constitutional scholar so i
have no idea how to answer that
any anybody no you should tweet it like
will chamberlain or somebody yeah
joshua cassell says i'm from ontario and
we have an enforced stay at home
starting at midnight
i can't legally see my girlfriend in
another city still going
also have to have to have note from work
to go to work now
i wonder if i could like hire people to
document what it's like to be in the
lockdown
as a media organization offer them up a
very light contract of like
man i'd love for you to be able to
document what it's like going to your
girlfriend's house
when this lockdown is in place i've got
a balance it's really interesting you
might see no cars no businesses
i'd like to hire someone to be able to
do that hey guess what you'll have to
drive to your girlfriends to do it and
you'll be at work i could write you a
note
yeah it's absolutely crazy what's
happening in canada in the united
kingdom and we have to understand this
is all happening under democratic rule
and most likely those same restrictions
are coming to the united states very
soon as well
that's why people got to get out of the
cities but we're seeing something
interesting we're seeing a blue
immigration into red areas and i was
talking to someone earlier who's uh very
conservative was like you can tell
because you know out here in the middle
of nowhere you got bears and stuff
and they'll post on next door that app
you guys know next door is the social
media for your zip code
and you can tell if they just moved here
because they're complaining about
a lot of what people are doing and it's
like i don't think you realized where
you moved to
no one is going to get your back on this
you're on your own quite literally
not disrespectfully just literally
everybody takes care of themselves
it's like you got animals put figure it
out go on the internet research what to
do about big bears coming on your
property because no one's going to help
you
help help call the police where where
are they
45 minutes away good luck yeah florida's
like another country when you go down
there i mean i think desantis is going
to be a contender in 24 just
in a big part and a big reason of that
is because of weight the way he
responded to kerber
yep jason stanek says hi tim and co i'm
just some random guy that registered
with the fec and ran a pathetic campaign
for president
thought i thought you might want to
check out my crappy website before i
take it down next week
my username dot com buy so uh jason
stanek2020 is his name let's see here
louis cintron says poland has a pending
contract with raytheon don't forget who
just joined the cabinet so does that
mean they're going to bend the knee
no no i don't know daniel nelson says i
think if parlor taught us anything
it's that when given the opportunity to
speak freely people will take that
opportunity
i personally took a few jokes too far on
there i'll own up to it
definitely i think there there is a a
real problem with
online anonymity it is a serious
challenge though
there are dissidents who face
persecution and prosecution
in their horrifying dictatorships if
they find out who's saying these things
at the same time there are people who
will never be held accountable for
saying
really disgusting and awful things and
they just love being nasty
we we really did build a culture of
being awful people on the internet kind
of bums me out we didn't build it the
algorithms incentivize
it no no i'm talking about going back to
comp you serve and and
i think people are well i've changed my
view on this people can be now assume
they're anonymous but actually i think
they're nastier when they have a face
and a name behind it because
then you've got the virtue signaling
incentive i'm going to condemn these
people and my reputation will go up an
ego to defend it
okay this one might be controversial you
ready for something controversial
raf meinster says mr bakari how was
ghost writing milo's book like uh
interesting is that is that true i mean
uh
you'd have to look into it and read the
reports oh is that what they're claiming
i don't know that's why i said maybe
it's controversial we'll leave it there
then
colin ki he says i don't know if i'm
just out of the loop but it seems like
parlor came out of nowhere
the first i'd ever heard of alt tech was
was sticks and he was talking about gab
mines and bit shoot but never parlor
that's true i don't understand why
parlor became the go-to app
gab already existed it had a lot of um
like mainline republican support a lot
of big donors
but they also did a lot of kyc where you
needed a phone number to join
and they admittedly worked with the
police
on many investigations as well
interesting
gareth green says further your oh is
there another one i'm missing from you
gareth this is the problem with uh
segmented
there we go garrett says tim you need to
understand that regulations violate
individual rights
corporations are legally individuals and
big tech regulations
are against everything that gop stands
for regulations are fascism
i disagree it's like there's a certain
level of too much power for government
and too much power for corporations
a regulation is not necessarily
in and of itself too much power if it's
restricting access
because it's holding something back i
think i'm totally in favor that i don't
know if you guys want to disagree
no i agree i mean aristotle's cycle of
regimes it's amazing how it happens to
almost every republic it descends into
oligarchy
yep gareth green says further your whole
thing about tech suppression will
destroy descent and competition forever
is incredibly short-sighted
because it only creates a market for
competition and moreover you forget how
new social media is
the free market will crush them in time
how's parlor doing i mean gab's doing
well because they're building the entire
infrastructure even their own browsers
and their own phones
but they have gone after every
competitor and tried to suppress them
and it's not just that youtube uses its
subsidy from google
to suppress any video competition the
one thing that really props up youtube
is the ability to make money
the one reason you can make money is
because youtube is subsidizing it to
make sure no one else can emerge in the
space
there are other platforms that have
tried to make money for people but they
just don't make
enough and so people don't use them
let's see robert poynter says hey went
to timcast.com today and became a member
love what you do keep it up and you can
become a member too
because tim cast irl is great i don't
know what what is this saying
is true it's good but it can be better
with members only content i'm gonna use
that line i like that
wonder woman 1984 was pretty bad but
that meme is pretty good of of pedro
pascal saying
life is is good but it can be better so
that's a good meme to use i'm gonna use
that one
all right let's see what else we got
here gareth green says the queen has
more power behind the scenes than anyone
anyone know she has an audience with the
prime minister every week
and no one knows what goes on between
them my idea is that instead of chief
executive the monarch could be the head
of the
the judiciary interesting i know you're
british right
you have an opinion on that uh i've
never heard that theory before
oh they she does have the meeting every
week with the prime minister and it's
true no one really knows what uh is
discussed there
oh sometimes sometimes you know there
are there are leaks and you know those
the whole netflix theories where they
you know realized it we have a very very
important one tom
drowlett says simping for ian stay real
brother yo homie
uh dad teaches and words to my son says
holy hell ian have some chicken noodle
soup and vitamin c and lots of water
oh okay thank you supportive odysseus
horse as ian we had a national bank when
president jackson who was against
centralized banking
proposed shutting it down the bank
threatened to collapse the economy
well they threatened the wrong man yeah
didn't he he like nuke him
and like shut down whatever the second
yeah i wouldn't mess with and they tried
to shoot him
they did shoot him wow what yeah he got
assassination attempt when he tried to
shut down the second
central bank wow and it was a span of 20
years that they shut it
shut the big bank down and that's why
they put him on the 20 bill allegedly
oh really yeah yes
double check that but last week was
unprecedented political violence never
before in american history
yeah never happened never happened yeah
it was actually you know that story
about that one guy what was his name
alexander hamilton
yeah totally made up never happened
dueling not a thing yeah just this
country nothing
last summer didn't happen yeah no no no
no yeah black lives matter
just something your parents made up to
scare you before bed make you make sure
you don't break the rules
all right let's see christian
mchatton says if you re-watch catch me
if you can the banking scene where he
goes in as a grifter and gets denied
then goes back in as a pilot and
commands the authority to cash his
checks
authority lies where people believe it
resides that's right
absolutely true that's why i ate for
free a lot with my press card
yeah walking into places like oh he's
got a press card you know we're scared
of him
tj fister says this is one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
trump is jack nicholson walking into the
asylum it culminates with the party the
dc riot
now nurse ratchet has shut it all down
and forcing us to take our pills to make
us behave
didn't he like break out the window and
then run away with no that was his
friend
he got lobotomized oh that's nice
great oh man
uh jordan muller says tim poole who has
ten dollars a month to spend on
basically what we're getting for free
let alone one thousand dollars a month
grifter shame oh
[ __ ] is that is that how much did you
spend on that super chat ten dollars
five dollars thank you for your money
yeah um
the website isn't just going to be
nothing we're gonna have exclusive live
streams and behind the scenes access
and you know segments and interviews we
literally launched it on monday
so it's like we just put it up i put it
up and we're actually gonna do events
too
so who has ten dollars a month well if
you don't i mean you don't don't then
watch the show do you ever see that
twitch girl who's like
was telling people to subscribe to her
channel i mean it's just it's just she
was like
you're not giving me money she's like
you do the show you are i don't even
wanna
this is this is what i love about the
future this show is free it's free on
all podcast platforms it is free to
watch live
it is you can comment in the chat
section and do all that stuff and then
we're gonna have a members only space
with
extra stuff so it's like you get a free
show
i don't you know people are discounts on
merch
i actually i you know i wanted to have a
ten
a five thousand a ten thousand a a
thirty thousand a fifty a one hundred
because if you don't ask the answer is
always no it's true right
so you throw it out there and then see
if someone throws a bunch of crazy money
at you for some
reason which they usually they they
basically don't but someone would send
like 10 million dollars in bitcoin to
that one guy
220. what's his name no no no no no
no i thought that they send quite a bit
they said quite a bit of bitcoin
i'm not sure how much exactly oh maybe
i'm thinking of somebody else
what's the guy's name that everyone's
like you gotta have him on the show you
got him on the show
no fuentes yeah yeah oh oh oh oh oh oh
then i heard this someone sounded like
millions of dollars in bitcoin
i was thinking of uh we're talking about
weave so he got sent like a million
dollars
oh wow oh wow yeah i was like no
yeah that'd be cool to be able to let
people pay with crypto to
sign up for the month that's really hard
to do yeah this grifting thing i mean no
one ever yells grifter at the washington
post for making you
pay to read lies yep yeah
xerocipher says things are so bad even
in canada i am called a white
sup i am the only white person in my
house i proved shelter to half uh
i provide shelter to a half native woman
and her kids rent free
the oldest calls me daddy and is half
asian but i am the problem
i fear not for my future but his that's
bummer
let's see shinjito says hey tim i'll
watch the live stream later but i wanted
to ask you
is there a way to become a member
through bitcoin or is it only paypal for
now
if so any idea when other payment
options will be implemented keep up the
good work probably just paypal for now
because i don't think we have the
infrastructure to build something like
that
maybe it should be built but there's
only so much due to complaints and the
internet can do
i think there's float.app that already
does something like this that allows
people to use cryptocurrencies for
subscription-based kind of uh profiles
daniel maxwell says at luke fake woke
comment i am
behalf of all non-human primates oh aunt
on behalf of all non-human primates i'm
offended by your shirt i hope
that one is on your site oh because it
is on my site yes
we are changing the workforce shirts
akabot says tim all phones are always
recording
if you thoroughly read all the
disclosures and end user license
agreements they will tell you this
all phones have most devices are
compromised and totally isn't everything
100
i actually did the story on this when i
believe it first started coming
out because you know phones have voice
activation
and so do the little devices used by you
know google and amazon
which means the microphones have to be
on otherwise
how would they know what you were saying
the other thing is the way they transl
they they know what you're saying is
they send the audio to a company that
transcribes it and then sends the text
as data and then they can use that
to translate there are some apps where
they'll like
say the word three times to record your
voice but they're they they don't work
that well
because you might say it'll be like say
your name and then you'll say
tim tim and then the next time you do it
you'll be like tim
and then they'll not register that it's
you so now they they do this whole thing
where they are constantly sending
that's why voice uh voice text doesn't
work when you don't have internet
so yes that i know they claim though
it's not actually
being used to uh you know record and
then sell it
because this is what they always say to
improve the service
i used to i held on my uh android fives
as long as i could because you could
take the battery out but these all have
embedded batteries
yeah i think you should check that
daniel bundrick says wild how many
people identify as libertarian but pay
no attention to the libertarian party
i think conservative thought leaders
should sign agreements to overthrow the
libertarian party
toss its leaders and turn it into a
party that intends to win
yeah i think um the libertarian
party may be the only real viable party
at this point
they could move forward mind fury says
love the show i think
libertarians will never ever win a
national election the united
for them yes st that would have
abandoned the gop
then you'd have a massive wave to
whatever party is viable
you're at that a near entirely new party
like a patriot party like some people
are talking about that's much more like
than the libertarians ever winning
anything they're just too
they're not going to win you don't think
so i mean they got what five million
votes last time
most people just see them as a joke
party yeah
let's see mind fury says love the show i
think youtube is mocking you
the jre show with you dorsey and vagia
has been queued up to play after this
uh well that's good isn't it especially
right now watch it
robert miller says hey luke ordered a do
a civil war shirt teespring says
violates policy so they won't make it
what up sarcasm is not allowed they
don't get satire i complained of course
what what happened you know that chair
where they're poking the thing yeah he
said it was
it's banned what uh i'm gonna double
check
that i didn't get it that's why my
shirts are silly like yeah
i mean the shirt i'm wearing is not
pretty serious right now oh they'll call
it racist
well if you would like to get an i am a
gorilla t-shirt make sure you go to
teespring.com
stores slash timkat you will know
i am a gorilla but we're just saying
your gorilla because it's funny
that's right it's a reference to the
book ishmael
and we've reappropriated the meme so
that it's immagrilla love yourself
so we also have a special valentine's
day shirt of a gorilla we're trying to
figure out exactly what it should look
like and
i'm i'm thinking it should be a
guerrilla screaming with spit coming out
his eyes going the wrong directions
demanding that you love yourself
well technically i have a gorilla on my
shirt and he believes that the
government is
the answer to our problems i think
that's a
chimp skull think that could be a
gorilla i don't know it could be
i think it is pretty sure it is okay
gorillas are apes so we are descended
from gorillas
we are not we shared a common ancestor
from apes right the great ape
from a primate of some sort oh cool
let's see kenneth anderson says hey tim
big fan of the show i just wanted to ask
you about your opinion on
growing support of texit oh is that
texas seceding from the union
i don't know man i don't think that'll
ever happen i think the united states
needs to remain unified and strong
because china is a serious threat and if
we broke up then china would just take
over and that's you know
pretty important let's just do uh one
more a couple let's do two more
ed says if trump gets impeached i am
never voting republican ever again
and i think others should do the same
right on
and charles bay uh balyozian says alum
great foresight with
hashtag deleted reading now and you're
on point also recognize
uh armenia i am also a gorilla
interesting well with that being said uh
people are yelling ishmael in the chat
uh with that being said though uh ellen
you wrote a book on tech censorship
called um deleted big text battle to
erase the trump movement and steal the
election
uh if you read books go and buy it at
deletedbook.com if you know someone who
reads books maybe uh someone two decades
older
older than you who doesn't know what a
youtube is uh give it to them as well
because everyone needs to understand
this threat even if they don't use the
internet
you've been covering the censorship
stuff for forever basically
essentially yes since since 2015 since
before anyone uh figured out it was
going to be a problem breitbart used it
because we saw
we saw how hostile the left had become
the free speech and we saw the internet
as the greatest platform of free speech
so it was inevitable that those two
trends would collide and they did
right on man well thanks for hanging out
tonight do you want to mention any other
social media or anything uh yeah thanks
for having me on tim uh i'm still
on twitter uh for now haven't been
banned yet
uh at libertarian blue a legacy from
when i didn't think libertarians were a
joke
but you can't but you can't change your
handle these days without getting
de-verified and you need that blue check
more than ever if you don't be shadow
band
uh you can also find me on gab at ab and
until recently at a big one of those
nice short handles
early adopter and until recently you can
find me on parlor at alan b
and maybe when they come back you can uh
find me there again and obviously
go to breitbart news if you want the
latest tech news articles
right on of course uh luke's hanging out
yeah my independent media channel is
we are change on youtube and
if you believe the government is the
answer to our problems
this shirt is not for you and you should
not go to
we are change dot org forward slash
shirts
to get one yourself that would also
support my
efforts here on this show so don't do
that remember do as you're told
unless you're a gorilla yes ian i hear
you have social media are you a gorilla
have you bought a i am a gorilla shirt
yes i do have social media tim
at ian crossland uh i pretty much have
cornerstone
on all the social networks except i
don't know if i'm on gab yet i might be
but i'm on youtube twitter facebook
instagram and minds
um come follow me on mines i co-founded
that we barely talked about mines today
but
along lines with gab and and parlor it's
it's uh
free software social network that m i d
m-i-n-d-s-d-s
yeah mine that's right and don't forget
you can follow at sour patch lads just
press all the buttons you can i
am this is true i am right now only on
twitter since parlor is gone
my handle is sour patch lids lyds and
then when i get on
gab i think i'm gonna have my hand will
be the same so i think i'll do that
today
wonderful and of course if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
hit the notification bell and if you
would like to protect
us from big tech censorship we are we've
got a lot of stuff in the works
you can go to timcast.com become a
member to get exclusive members only
content
which will be coming soon there are also
some issues people are having with
logins so just bear with us
as we're getting everything ramped up
but our goal is my goal i should say
this is
if we can get a dedicated and large
enough support base for members
we will be totally insulated and free
from any threats of real censorship
you know i've had timcast.com for some
time and it was just like hey donut if
you want to
and i really decided to lean into this
because you know more importantly
many successful podcasts thrive only off
of their core
users and members and those who really
support the show and that allows them to
well allows them that protection and
that freedom and you know they have to
worry about getting banned from youtube
i'm hoping that we can reach that level
what that means is if you are a member
the exclusive content you will get will
probably be a bit more bombastic
and the uncensored access to some of
these segments with some of our guests
which we'll start producing soon and
again we're also going to have in-person
live events for very small crews
so the goal is we're gonna have like
comedians and political commentators and
pundits
musicians doing shows on site and a
small select group of members well you
know we're gonna put on email saying
tickets are available
first come first served but then the
events will be live streamed
and we'll do special member access
streams and interviews and things like
that so we have a big plan in the works
to get this you know up and running and
just more than what it is now
and uh we could use your support so
again timcast.com don't forget to
like i said like share and subscribe you
can follow me on twitter instagram and
minds
at tim cast you can check out my other
channels youtube.comcast
and youtube.comcastnews we will be back
tomorrow
at 8pm live thank you all so much for
hanging out and we will see you all then
bye guys
you